yes
morning
thank you
blue
hello
oh yeah can you hear me
i can't hear him
so we can't hear
uh
can you see
hello
you hear me
um
you okay
bye
um
i'm in a position
now
yeah one two one
here we go
thank you
uh
okay
[Music]
is
[Music]
right
try again am i i'm not not tech away
anymore am i that's good thank you
it's okay now
are we all okay to continue
can you take your seats please
i said a moment ago the inquiry is now
resumed
but a lot to get through today so i'll
try and crack on
um
first couple of housekeeping things
should be a fresh attendance list
circulating today so please put your
details on that
even if you're not speaking
and
if you've got a mobile phone with you
please make sure it's switched off or on
silent whilst the inquiry is sitting
just as a
brief introduction to what we're hoping
to get through today
once i finished a few opening
announcements
um the appellants are
fielding their air quality expert
through the team's meeting
um for questions to be put by the rule
six party and mr gardner also indicated
he may have a question
[Music]
then when we've moved through that it'll
be mr pycroft giving the
appellants planning evidence
and then later today we need to
have sessions to deal with conditions
the section 106 agreement
but that's the
intention for today let me just first of
all say
another couple of things i need to go
through
one
hopefully the parties have been
contacted by
the inspectors case officer
i did receive an email which appears to
have been centered a minute past
midnight last night from
ashley harrison
it was down to speak on the opening day
of the inquiry but was unable to attend
because he tested positive
or covered
he asked me to
accept his
statement um because of
what he termed exceptional circumstances
um and he was particularly concerned
that when
mark francois mp
uh addressed the inquiry he he had to
shorten his address
and mr harrison was concerned that um
information that he'd provided to
the mp hadn't been put before the
inquiry i'll come on to that in a moment
but
in all the circumstances i decided to
accept mr harris's statement as a
written representation
and told him that
he needn't attend
the inquiry unless miss reed has any
questions that she wishes to put to him
miss reed have you had a chance to look
at the
information from
um
um very briefly sir um no objection to
it being submitted particularly given
the circumstances um haven't really had
a chance to
look at it in detail don't anticipate
that i'll have any questions if we do
need to come back to you in respect of
any points once we've had a look at it
then i'll ask your permission to do so
at that particular point
um i don't i don't think we will
necessarily but obviously we've not
given that it came in this morning had a
proper opportunity to have a have a read
through okay thank you for that
um
i do want however to make three points
for the benefit of other people present
today and for those watching the live
stream
um firstly i did say to mr harrison that
notwithstanding the fact that he'd
tested positive for covid if he was down
to speak
he could have known that he was required
to submit a statement
a week before
attending so that was the 18th of
january
so there's no real
reason i've not been given any
indication why
he couldn't comply with that
secondly accepting that it didn't arrive
before the inquiry it still could have
come in any time last week and could
have been before the inquiry so that all
parties would have had more time to
consider its content
and thirdly although
the mp was requested to summarize his
originally
submitted statement that was because the
statement was much longer um than uh
required under the inquiry procedure
rules and a statement of that length
should be accompanied by
a summary
of around fifteen hundred words which is
why i'd asked um mr franz mars to
summarize his submission
but he was also assured that his full
submission was before the inquiry
so
notwithstanding what mr harrison has
said uh anything that
was in mr francoise original statement
is before the inquiry and all
parties to the inquiry are able to see
and i can certainly take on board
anything that was in that original
statement
anyway notwithstanding that i've
accepted the
um statement as a written submission
second thing i wanted to move on to very
briefly is the site visit um
i i think
a suggested itinerary was
put forward by the council um where we
whereby we meet i can't remember the
exact location but i think it's 8 20
tomorrow morning that seemed to be
generally accepted the the only change
to
what um
what i thought was the situation
yesterday is i understand from the rule
6 party that
they they would like to accompany me
when i uh visit the appeals site itself
and also uh have
indicated um the percy cottage road
junction which to be fair i think wasn't
on the original
agenda so yes certainly we will do
that but but of course the fact that um
the rules sixth party want to accompany
me means that i need to be accompanied
by someone from the council and someone
from the appellant as well so
it'll be uh
we'll all all be attending
and before i um adjourn
today i'll check with you who is ending
site visit so i know
who i'm expecting to meet
tomorrow yep so if i may just in respect
to the site visit um no issue with
an
accompanied site visit um onto the site
itself as requested
um
in terms of permission for those that
are able to come on obviously it's
important that there's a at least one
representative from each party so the
rule six party the council
and the appellant i think there might be
some difficulties in terms of securing
permission for large numbers of people
to come onto the appeal site so it's
just a request at this stage that it
it's limited to
a representative from the council
the appellant and the rule six party
rather than just sort of being opened up
to everybody it's going to be difficult
for us to secure landowner consents i i
have no idea yet how many people are
expecting to attend i mean
i've made it quite clear that there's no
discussion about any merits of the case
at the site visit so yes people can
attend but as miss reed has rightly said
the the appellant is quite entitled to
restrict access onto the appeal site
itself as long as i'm accompanied by
someone from each of the main parties so
as i say i will i don't need to delay
proceedings now but before i adjourn
today i will check who's anticipating
attending the site visit tomorrow thank
you
um
other few other things i i've seen an
email not had time to really digest it
fully but regarding the signing of the
section 106 agreement so that will be
dealt with later today no doubt
um just two housekeeping matters from us
sir if i may if you've finished your
well
one more one more which was simply to uh
to say that i sent out some comments on
my look through the conditions
and
i
i don't think they've necessarily been
taken on board yet but hopefully they
can be prior to uh
prior to the inquiry session later later
today
um i think that's that's all i needed to
say so
thank you sir just in respect for your
final point we've been discussing the
conditions with the council and
hopefully that will your points will
have been taken on board and there'll be
an updated list um prior to the
condition session
in terms of other housekeeping matters i
just have two
the first one i've already handed to the
rule six party in the council
it's just
you'll recall in terms of air quality
that what we have
um in respect of the evidence is a
report that's attached to mr gascoigne's
evidence
so i've asked mr grubb who's going to be
speaking on behalf of the appellant in
respect to these matters just to put
forward a brief introduction setting out
his qualifications for your note sir and
also his statement of truth which i can
obviously take him to so that's all that
is
um
so if i may pass that up
um and then the second one sir is just
you'll recall that and when mr blair was
giving his evidence
um he was making um some points about
trip distribution and he took you to an
unpaginated page in the ta and we said
we'd get you a copy of it so not new
evidence it's in the core documents but
it's just to assist you in finding the
page that he was
he was looking at so i'll pass that up
and um i'll just ask a copy
who behind it thank you a copy to be
handed to the rule six party in the
council as well
okay it also has on the front of it
we've just written the reference within
the
core documents as well um to assist you
in terms of locating it with me
thank you
okay that's all from yourself
parkinson's anything from the council
no so nothing for me thank you mr foster
anything from the rule six party before
we begin
nope
okay so
breaking new ground here we're going to
try and do the uh the teams session
so
camera on i said
yeah let me yeah okay so
let me just do this and all your
your microphones uses because these
sounds
should come through your mic
yeah that's how it should work so just
check that um simon can hear you
yes can you hear me yes
right
i i think i'm i think i'm more or less
set up there my
camera's on my microphone's muted and
i'm using this microphone so can
everyone yeah get a thumbs up from the
back right okay
and i can see other participants so
that's helpful
that um only um sarah and simon are
actually on the screen when you're
asking questions
um
well i
i don't know uh i i think four four c
four seems reasonable but um you know if
if
if there's a problem we can we can
obviously adjust that but uh
let's go with that to start with so
basically what i'm
wanting now is misread for you to
introduce mr grubb
do whatever you need to in chief as it
were with him then
i'll
ask mr foster
what questions he has okay
thank you very much sir um good morning
mr grub can you hear me
yes thank you good morning um
your name is i'm just going to go to
your um statement of truth document that
you we've just handed up your name is
simon grubb you are a full member of the
institute of environmental sciences and
the institute of air quality management
with over 10 years extensive experience
of working within the private sector
delivering a wide range of environmental
assessments
including air quality and odor impact
assessments is that correct
is correct
you set out your uh qualifications in
respect of air quality uh bsc honours
m.a member of the institution of
environmental sciences a member of the
institution of air quality management is
that correct
correct
you set out in 1.3 that you undertook
the original air quality assessment
dated december 2019 that's within the
core documents and also the addendum air
quality assessment dated december 2020
and you have also overseen the
production of the technical note dated
december 2021 and that's the technical
note that can be found attached to mr
gascoigne's proof of evidence that
appendix iii is is that
right and can you please just read out
your statement of truth at paragraph 1.4
to the inquiry
the evidence provided is my full and
complete evidence i am i can confirm
that the evidence is my true a
professional opinion thank you very much
now um i'm going to take the documents
largely as read but just a few points of
clarification
um please and first point first point
can you just outline please to what
degree there was an agreement with the
council's environmental health officer
in respect of the scope and methodology
of the assessments that you undertook
the scope was agreed with the
appropriate environmental health officer
at the council and it was all agreed
uh second point please second point
um
what was the conclusion of the council's
environmental health officer
in respect of um the
impacts of of the scheme and i think you
you summarize this
um
at
paragraph 1.5 and 1.6 of the statement
and i know that there's also a statement
of common ground isn't there
yes the
environmental health officer um
well in the committee report he
concluded that the
that it's not coming through all that
clearly to me there i don't know no what
what options we have there perhaps
one one option clearly is mr grubbs
speak very slowly
i i don't know i don't know if that is
going to assist
it's just
i would just like to add that i was
getting a little bit of feedback then
myself um
i don't know
i'll um
in terms of the technical notes
the conclusions of the
air quality assessment at subsequent
air quality data
i'm getting feedback again actually i've
brought it to the
can i just can we just try maybe other
than
me and miss mr grubham and i can maybe
try turning other cameras off because i
know sometimes with teams that seems to
have a magical
effect
right
that's my camera off
i i thought that did sound a little bit
clearer that time yeah
i'll try again hopefully this time it
works
the conclusion to the air quality is
air quality
addendum
cutting out i'm afraid
okay
mr grub if you try turning your speaker
and your microphone down a little
does mr grubb have a headset at all that
often
improves matters let's try try again
no
no
um
can you hear us
i can hear you can you hear me better
now
yeah that was better that sound that
sounds better so just just try again in
terms of the answer
we try for the people
the conclusions of the air quality
assessment and subsequent addendum air
quality assessment were reported to the
development committee in the offices
report dated 26 of november 2020
paragraphs
3.150 through to
3.162 of that document confirmed that
the eho has commented on the submitted
air quality assessment and the addendum
air quality assessment and confirms that
the proposed amendment will not have an
unacceptable impact in terms of air
quality exposure of any pedestrians in
and around the site
thank you uh that was fifth time lucky i
think with that one
right um what i just want to take you to
now please is your um append sorry your
paragraph 2.3 2.3 of your statement
that's attached to mrs degascoin's proof
and there was a concern expressed by
interested parties
that receptor locations in the vicinity
of the holt farm schools and
the rochford day nursery
and um saint teresa's catholic primary
school
hadn't been assessed is that correct
uh
that was during a discussion with the
environmental health officer that
that was discussed and that wasn't then
addressed in the addendum air quality
assessment
thank you
couldn't we couldn't hear that clearly
sorry okay
mr grubb can just repeat repeat that
yeah i'm sorry to have to ask you to
speak slowly mr grub it's
it's not meant to be patronizing or
anything it's just that unfortunately in
this room
it is a little bit muffled and it breaks
up from time to time so
just
take it a few words at a time and let's
see how it goes the what you said a
moment ago was quite a bit clearer so
hopefully
in respect to those sector locations
that was discussed with the
environmental health officer
during the consultation process and that
was addressed those receptor locations
were addressed
in the addendum air quality assessment
thank you and if we turn up the plan if
we turn up the plan
which is um at page 12
of your statement
appendix b
do we see there
do we see there the receptor
locations that were assessed
yes
thank you and then just for the benefit
of members of the public that may not
have your statement in front of you at
them sorry could you turn up page seven
and it's a table
where you are setting out your response
to the rule six party comments
and i'd like you just by way of
conclusion
to read out
the in the ac response
um column the first two paragraphs
beginning the aqa addendum
yes aqa addendum
explicitly considers impacts as a result
of operational development generated
traffic at teresa's catholic primary
school rochefort day nursery and halt
farm junior
school by identifying receptors at these
locations furthermore the junction of
washington road hall road west road have
also been explicitly modelled
concentrations of pollutants at all
receptors including those identified to
be represented of the aforementioned
schools are predicted to be
well below the relevant national air
quality objectives
and impacts at these receptors are
predicted to be inedible for all
pollutants considered
the results of the
addendum air quality assessment were
accepted by
richard's environmental health officer
and confirmed in the committee report of
november 2020
thank you and that's the summary as i
understand to the detailed points that
are set out in that addendum air quality
assessment is that correct mr grub
great
thank you very much if you wait there
there'll be some questions for you
okay thank you mr grubb so mr foster for
the rule six party what what questions
have you got for mr gruber
thank you sir
all right thank you
i'm asking questions
around the
original addendum october 2020
the
air monitor air quality assessment
first of all does rochefort district
council have automatic air quality
monitoring stations
double check no they do not
could you tell me which is the only
roadside non-automatic site close enough
to the site for verification purposes
that would be the
ambulance sutton road
that is a roadside cycle model
verification sorry so i couldn't catch
that clearly
yeah could you could you repeat that
please please
as set out in the both
air quality reports the model has been
verified against a roadside location on
the
amberlin
the ambulance sutton road okay gambling
sutton road junction
which is quite a long way would you
agree from
the hall row sorry the halt farm schools
and the day nursery and the centuries
it is to move in an acceptable distance
to verify an air quality dispersion
model
so you say are you saying it is close
enough
to evaluate the air quality outside
school
it is within an acceptable distance to
um
as a verification point for the air
quality dispersion model used within the
assessment
sorry remains difficult to be clear is
that
it's close enough to monitor air quality
at the whole farm school yes or not
mr foster i think you dropped out for a
second there
was that a yes or no
okay
are you saying
excuse me
excuse me are you saying that the
roadside non-automatic monitor at the
ambulance roundabout is close enough to
monitor air quality outside hot farm
school
it's an appropriate location to verify
the model
that wasn't my question
is it close enough you broke out again
is it close enough
to verify the air quality outside the
halt farm schools
it is appropriate
location to verify all right could i
have an answer yes or no yes or no
please
it is not representative
of
the receptor location your ufo mentioned
the model is verified against this
location to make sure it is acceptably
working and then the traffic data is
input in
and then receptors are modeled at such
locations
so let me try and answer the question in
the way that i think you're trying to
explain the answer to my question was no
it's not satisfactory for monitoring air
quality at the whole farm school
is that correct
you you mentioned about verifying the
model
right
try again let me try again so the
ambulance sutton
monitoring location
is not at the same location
as you
mentioned
so you will in reality you will not get
the same concentration
exactly the same concentrations
ambulance so theoretically if you're
trying to
what you're trying to ask me is that the
is the ambulance road
site
representative
of the school the answer is no right
thank you
um what is the mean the annual mean
objective
for nitrogen dioxide pollution
in micrograms per cubic meter of
air
could you tell me what the site results
had been for
the roadside monitoring at the anne
berlin roundabout for the previous four
years against that 40 objective
in 2019 we were 38.4
in 2018 we were 40.8
in 2017 we were 42.4
2016 were 42.09
so three of those four years it was over
the national objective is that correct
sorry i did i did miss i didn't hear the
first word you said a good question so
for three of those four years
the results had been above the
annual mean objective of 40.
that is correct
thank you
is it true that defra recognizes that
emissions have not declined as expected
from diesel vehicles
historically that was the case
but
that has since been
retracted
and the institute of air quality
managers have confirmed this in a
position statement does that sit in any
of the evidence presented i couldn't
find it there
you broke up again
sorry what your statement you've just
made about that you've been retracted by
defra
is that presented in any of the evidence
you've put forward
i'll hear you mr foster sorry
okay
you said
that the defra statement had been
retracted
is that correct so that i said the
thinking behind that has now
has now changed and then a position
statement
by um
the institute of air quality managers
means we don't it's historically within
air quality assessment we had to
consider that diesel diesel cars were
not reducing as as previously predicted
but now
the position the position is that so we
had to do a position normally
historically we had to do a sensitivity
test to consider this
but now we don't have to do that anymore
because it's starting to see that
emissions are reducing as as expected
within and are reflected with the
emission factor toolkits used within the
modeling
okay so i'll repeat my question
the statement you just made was that
submitted in evidence
that is set out in the addendum air
quality assessment report
that we don't have to do these
sensitivity assessments anymore okay so
what what is the
if there's been a retraction what is the
um shall we say new annual mean
objective
the annual meet objective's still 40
we're not from dark side
so it's still 40. okay
okay so we've got the just to summarize
that short discussion we've got a
situation where the nearest roadside
monitoring
you accept isn't
sufficient to monitor air quality
at the halt farm school
and despite all of that three out of the
four years we talked about it was
actually over the
um
the main objective
all right i'll move on now
in the proposal i'm so sorry
no i'm so sorry that was a statement not
a question and i'm not sure it did
actually reflect what my witness had
said in respect of the evidence so i'm
quite happy for mr foster to put that as
a question to my witness but not as a
statement which with respect miss
summarizes the evidence he's just it was
it was your summary of how you viewed
that interchange but in fairness you
should ask mr grubb
whether that represents what he's told
you okay
okay
is the summary i just made correct
can you uh
just
make that summary again please
just so i don't miss anything
sorry i couldn't couldn't hear that
clearly can you uh repeat your summary
please just so i can make sure
that i'm confirming okay
we still have the situation
that the
roadside air quality monitoring
at the
ann berlin roundabout which for three of
the four years
has been over the national mean target
this is still the case
and that that
isn't uh appropriate for measuring the
air quality at the whole farm school
do you agree yes
yes
thank you
in the proposed statement of common
ground which we never ever brought to a
conclusion
for reasons which i don't understand
i asked where there was no monitoring of
air quality near ashton road schools or
the day nursery at hall road do you know
the answer that they gave
no
okay
okay the answers they said was the site
does not lie within or close
cut out against the foster right
the answer they gave was that the site
does not lie within or close to a
designated air quality management area
the nearest being rayleigh 10 kilometers
away
does that mean that there's not an air
quality issue near the schools
the local authority have the obligation
to monitor
air quality and report it annually
the council must assume and
as is evident in our air quality
assessment
and demonstrated air quality is not
considered a concern
so sorry
it is very difficult to understand
what's being said i john repeat the
question
um
okay
because the site is not within
or close to a designated air quality
management area the nearest being
rayleigh 10 kilometers away that was a
response to my question about why there
was no monitoring near the schools
and my question was does this mean there
is not an air quality issue near the
schools
if the council the council are obliged
to monitor air quality and obviously
it's their judgment to monitor where
they think this is going to be an issue
so
is the answer yes or no
[Music]
dude
without without without any monitoring
there's no
i can't conclude that there wouldn't be
an issue at the site
so the answer is we don't know
about this definitively we don't know
sorry did you agree with me that we
don't know
do you agree with me that we don't know
about monitoring we don't know
sorry mr grover i didn't i didn't hear
your answer then
did you
no
we don't know
okay so we don't know
no
is it true
that
only
road traffic emissions have been modeled
that is true that's correct
okay
and it also says in the report and it
mentions in the context of only road
traffic emissions have been modeled
it says due to the absence of other
sources in the area and that's on page 3
2.5
is that correct
the addendum
or i think you're being asked whether
that was the addendum
[Applause]
write with the paragraph number please
i'll i'll quote if i may surfer
clarification
it says for the purpose of this
assessment and due to the absence of
other sources in the area only road
traffic emissions have been modeled
i was just checking that and the answer
was yes is that correct
yes okay
so what other sources could be
considered
over and above
traffic emissions
yes
sorry what what other sources could be
considered other than traffic emissions
uh point sources could could be
considered such as any say heart vessel
you had a an
incinerator in the area
sorry i'm sorry that was so sorry sir
that wasn't clear i didn't know whether
you could hear it
i i was your question what other sources
could be considered yes
i didn't hear your answer mr foster
i i i didn't hear that second one i i
thought the first time i heard you say
point sources such as an incinerator
yeah that could be an example of another
source that could be considered it's
just an example we didn't
okay perhaps i could just
explore
sorry i'm
handling the
poor quality is a bit difficult
my question was what other sources could
be considered so i'll expand on that
for example could the
potential hgv traffic over the nine
years of the development of the site
be significant should that be considered
or was it estimated
sorry can you put yourself at the end of
that question sorry
okay
other sources okay
has any assessment be made of the impact
or potential impact
of hgv traffic up and down ashton road
for the several years of the
development
the assessment is based upon traffic
data that was provided by uh
ardent transport
and consulting engineers
so
in line with the transport assessment
sorry i i can't hear mr foster again
it's not
well can i can i just check it is your
question to do with potential
construction traffic if the development
was supposed to be the procedure
construction traffic over the several
years of the period the reason i
mentioned that is it says in the absence
of other sources in the addendum so i'm
just trying to check sir whether
other potential sources have been
considered or not or if they could be
yes i i think it's all it's not a
different source it's still road traffic
emissions isn't it but you're you're
specifically asking whether or not
construction traffic and htvs
associated with that have been taken
into account all the assessments to date
have been on current
and recent
not projecting what the impact of the
construction on air quality
i don't know if you followed that mr
grubb there i think i think you're being
asked about the potential for
um
air quality impacts from construction
traffic if this development was to
proceed
that would there was no request to uh
consider a separate
impact scenario by the local authority
for construction traffic
so does do you mean
that it would be a potential source of
increased air quality
pollution but it wasn't considered
because it wasn't asked for
well i i can't answer that question
really because i can't advise whether it
would be
what level of impact it would be
because i wasn't asked to do it
okay
so we don't have any
indication in any report that of the
impact on air quality of any future hgv
construction traffic
thank you
does it include domestic sources for
example gas boilers which most houses
have is the impact of that on the air
quality being assessed in and around the
area of the schools
no it's not a standard requirement they
normally
could it be
could it be
assessed
you normally that what normally happens
is they normally set a a
emissions limit for boiler
obviously as technology changes we're
moving away from boilers sorry i don't
again i'm sorry it's not very clear the
same
my question was could it be
i didn't hear that mr foster sorry my
question was quite simply
could
domestic sources of air quality
pollution could they be assessed
it could be but it's not it's not a
normal thing to be done okay
we don't okay you don't normally assess
a single individual boiler so they could
be but they weren't is that correct
that's correct thank you
did you see the live stream last week
when we were talking about pollution
sorry
sorry did you see the live stream last
week of the um
the hearing
was it yes with this respect to your
ribbons
yes indeed sir we took a small sample of
ribbons that have been on the
guard rail outside the school
and we put them in boiling water
and
what we got was
this
from that small bag which has got
droplets of tar in the bottom sorry
droplets of tar in the bottom
you can probably see on the screen there
yes
and when you shake we need a question mr
foster please no okay
so
having seen that would you agree that
ribbons from the safety barrier are
around the head head height of most of
the primary school children or toddlers
approximately without measuring i don't
know but i said roughly okay
well
okay let me try another specific
question so
assuming the young children whose heads
are level with those
those ribbons
would you agree that the children are
therefore breathing in pollution
everyone will be breathing in pollution
so is that a yes
yes
right thank you
do you know
has any study considered the polluting
impact of the loss of a mature oak tree
this wasn't requested during the
planning process
okay so that's a no
no
do you know what percentage of pollution
matter is absorbed by a mature oak tree
that'd be a question for an ecologist
okay so the answer is you don't know
yep
um do you know how long it takes for
saplings to mature enough to compensate
for the loss of a mature oak tree
um just for the record the research
we've done so i'm sorry sir yeah
it's it's not uh appropriate to give me
your statement there you you've asked
questions of this witness
um may i ask are we able to get an
ecologist to answer those questions
um i i i i i'm sorry sir we asked
specifically i
i'm quite happy for my air quality
expert to attend and give evidence but
we asked specifically at the case
management conference whether any
evidence was going to be given by the
rule 6 party in respect of air quality
matters what we had in the evidence that
was produced was a general concern in
respect to the monitoring locations
and in respect of how the assessment had
been carried out
that was the extent of the evidence
would you mind speaking to the
microphone we couldn't hear that i said
that was the extent of the sorry the
whole speech please couldn't hear it
we asked at the case management
conference for the rule six party to be
clear as to what its case was going to
be
in respect of air quality so that we
could put appropriate provision in place
for our witnesses to be available to
answer the rule six parties question
so we've done that based on the evidence
that the rule six party has provided in
its statement which raised a specific
concern
in respect to the points that have been
put thus far to my witness quite
properly by mr foster but if we're now
extending the debate in relation to
other matters which involve for example
ecological points
so i'm afraid
with respect that's that's going beyond
the scope of the evidence that's been
produced
yes i mean
may i respond well before you before you
do
the the point is we did explore this at
the case management conference and you
were quite specific that
you you weren't going to be putting
forward air quality evidence over and
above what was in the statement and then
as the run-up to the inquiry progressed
you you did indicate that you were going
to put forward a witness and then you
said you weren't
and so there is no evidence before the
inquiry from the rule six party on
the points that you're now
wanting to put forward and certainly not
the points that you're you're seeking to
explore now okay
i mean that that
we are exploring air quality sir as we
said we would in the case management
conference
what we said we wouldn't explore was the
impact on the conservation area no no
that's not strictly true mr foster you
you you indicated about the um
conservation area but you certainly gave
no indication that that the
evidence from the rule six party would
extend beyond what was in your statement
regarding air quality
you you've already raised a variety of
matters that are
new to the inquiry in terms of ribbons
and
um
your jar i mean all of this information
could have been put forward
at the appropriate time as is the norm
with inquiry preparation
so it's it's not reasonable for you to
now be seeking to extend way beyond that
could i say please sir that um we tried
to have these discussions in the
statement of common ground process and
we were ignored
i'm sorry sir that is a point that has
now been made on numerous occasions that
i have not responded to but i'm afraid
it is incorrect
as mr pycroft will indicate when he
gives his evidence but sir
really tried not to interrupt the rule
six party as points have been raised
that have not been raised in evidence
because i accept that they
are
doing their best to present the concerns
that arise to them but there really is a
limit in terms of what the appellant can
be expected to deal with and now we're
in the realms of technical evidence
straying outside points where we
expressly asked for clarification to be
given at a much earlier stage and i'm
afraid to that extent it is now at a
point where i have to object to that
going any further
my response may i respond sir all the
questions we've asked about air quality
and we said we would raise air quality
and we have
if um if the witness is not able to
answer the
impacts related to the loss of the
ability to absorb pollution
by the tree
and
then
so be it that's your decision sir
information to that effect has been put
forward i can't remember where i've seen
it but in terms of whether it's
interested persons statements or
whatever so that that information
is before me but we can't take it any
further with this witness
fine that's that's the end of my
question sir thank you okay you sure
okay thank you
um
mr gardner indicated at the end of last
week that he had a
a question that he wanted to put
to yes i think mr garner if you don't
mind if you if you can come
to that laptop i think that's the only
way we're going to be able to to work
this
i do have a few questions if that's okay
as long as they don't repeat points that
have already been pete they're all
important questions because people's
lives and health are affected by this
development
good morning
morning mr gardner hello
um
right the first question i've got to ask
is it was brought up when i was speaking
last monday
about gas boilers this mostly current
controls around climate change although
it does affect local areas but um
there's 62
662 properties being built am i correct
that's what the applications for and
they will all have a condensing gas
boiler
i don't know i don't know the answer to
that whether each individual property
would have a condensing gas boiler
because looking at blur's development so
far that's what they've put in they put
no
renewable energy boilers in now you know
a condensing gas boiler
produces more co2 than the average
boiler it was a mistake that was made
when they were bought air in 2000
and the average
condensing gas boiler will produce
21 kilograms of co2 per year sorry
that's what fully grown tree will absorb
25 21 kilograms of co2
per year
the um
mr gardner i'm going to have to say to
you it's not going to be particularly
profitable if you give a lot of figures
what what right because that's the thing
that's you making a statement what what
i need you to do is to cut through that
and get to the question that you want to
put to this witness and we'll see
whether or not he can he's able to
respond if not you'll have to just move
on to the next
question with those boilers you will
need to plant uh so many trees per year
want you to counteract the co2 emissions
how many does the appellant plan to pull
on
that would be
not that that would be a question for an
ecologist again or the climate change
consultant not an air quality consultant
i'm so i'm so sorry sir i think
that the scope of this witness is
evidence in respect of the air quality
matters that are set out in the
statements and the air quality
assessments
i'm not sure that these are points that
properly go to
his evidence
yeah i mean i i'd have have you had the
opportunity to look through the evidence
that
mr has put forward never seen it no well
that's that's really what you should be
aiming your questions at you should be
questioning this witness on the scope of
his evidence
okay then
right we know there's an average of
eighteen thousand cars use yeshendon
road per day
um
um the next vehicle is actually not cars
that's purely vehicles every day of the
year
um right we start with
the actual building this construction
how are you going to stop
the pollution emissions that will be
coming out there
co
co hydrocarbons nitrous oxides and
particulate matter
i don't understand what the question is
pan
how are we going to
stop i think you need to clarify clarify
what you're actually
saying there right the environmental
impact of the construction machinery
yes
what is that going to be
the levels of pollution from that
machinery
you want about the stationary plant that
will be moving across the site
are you referring to the machinery that
will be used on site yes on site in
construction machinery
appropriate
appropriate machinery will be used and
it will all be assumed it will be set
out in the construction environmental
management plan
so will there be an impact on that yes
or no
there will obviously be a temporary
impact
right and do you know how much that is
no because it's not in the scope of our
our assessment should we agree with the
local authority well according to the
government's guidance in that that
should all be worked out we
i don't need your statements mr gardner
at this point uh
it's difficult i know but please try and
stick to putting questions to the
witness rather than making statements
which may well be repeating matters you
said when you made your statement
what actually method was used at the
ambolin
to detect air quality
a diffusion tube
can you
do uh check nitrous oxides am i correct
no i should die outside yes
so what about pm2
pm 10 10
which are even more dangerous
local pollutants
none of that's been checked
the local authority have no pm10 or pm
2.5 monitors so with
the
traffic about um lorries and that
bringing materials in taking them away
you don't know what their pollution
levels are do you
they've been
traffic scenarios have been modeled
which consider
pm10 and pm 2.5 what have you modeled
that
scenario
truck the the pollutants pm10
and pm 2.5 have been modelled and asked
in respect to traffic
and are set out in the air quality
assessments what figures have you used
on pm 2.5 and pm10 sorry
you cut out again what methods have you
used to determine what p 2.5 is and pm 2
1 0 is
you mean pm10 and pm 2.5 yes
the same method that we've used to model
nitrogen dioxide it's the same model
emission factor toolkits provided by
defra
but you didn't actually put in the
correct method uh
quality in
sorry i you broke up again you're not
actually using proper figures you're
only guessing that what you're going to
get
i'm basically upon death for emission
factors toolkits which is set out in the
uh
in both air quality reports
um i'm not getting any based upon the
traffic data provided well i'm afraid
that is a guess because i've got the
actual measurements of p 2.5 pm 2.5 mpm
10 in the area i needed those because
i'm actually doing a university course
on climate change
and pollution
and these figures are accurate and
they're virtually near world health
organization levels
i'm so sorry sir once again and i do
hesitate to interrupt but once again
this information in respect of the air
quality assessments has been
before the inquiry and has been
considered through the application
process and publicly available for an
extremely long time and mr gardner has
given his evidence the inquiry also and
we're now having new statements being
put to my witness that are not reflected
in the evidence that's been given
i'm not quite sure
mr gardner
you've already indicated that you
haven't looked at the air quality
evidence that's been submitted
by the appellant
i
i don't know if you can explain why you
haven't done that but that's not really
material here the point is the inquiry
process requires evidence that's going
to be relied on at the inquiry to be
submitted in accordance with
an agreed timetable and certainly
just producing something out of a hat as
it were when a witness is on the stand
isn't an appropriate way to deal with
this
you
you have had opportunity had you have so
wished to have put information in well
before now
i think what you need to do as i said a
moment ago is rather than trying to
introduce your own evidence at this
extremely late stage you need to put
questions to the witness who's
speaking to the reports that he has
prepared
right there is a reason i'm asking all
this um so in actual fact no correct
proper air quality measurements have
done they've only been models from
defra and other places
so there's been no equipment that's been
produced down here to actually measure
air quality as there
a modeling process has been undertaken
and verified against a diffusion tube
location
as per agreed with the local authority
effusion jews do not major can you let
let the widows finish
but we've used a standard methodology
which has been agreed by the local
authority to assess the impacts on
nitrogen dark side pm10 and pm 2.5
right but it has not actually been
measured that day so it's all on what
the local authority has
said well the local authority are duly
obliged to monitor air quality correctly
within their jurisdiction but they don't
measure
what they've just said it's more of a
matter of that
they have to be accurate
but they don't measure pm 2.5 or pm one
zero do they
the local authority don't know which are
uh considered now by the world health
organisation to be serious
pollutants
a world health organization guidelines
that sets that
that sets out some new
thinking but these have not been
transposed into the uk standards
in respect to pn10 and pm 2.5
right
so the next question is
if you don't know the correct air
quality
pollution levels
you don't know what impact your building
is going to have on it do you
as previously advised
the scope of assessment was discussed
and the methodology to assess pn10 and
pm25 2.5 was agreed with the local
authority and it was deemed an
acceptable approach it's the same
approach i do across the country
but but you still don't know whether it
will affect
the people living in the area
as i just advised we've we've done an
assessment on stamp
agreed agreed approach
and concentrations
have been modeled
and we're not seeing any exceedance on
the standards the current standards air
quality standards
so that that that would indicate that
we're not having an adverse impact
all right last question is um
and i can find it
are you aware of the high court judgment
in england and wales high court
where a building developments
and local authority
were against each other on air pollution
the actual inspector
turned down initially
in inquiry
because they could not come up with that
answer whether it would affect the
levels because they're near the
remaining levels anyway and then it went
to higher court and it was thrown out
then are you aware of that
that's that's a rather
rather vaguely put question yeah i don't
want to read through the whole lot it
was the case on air pollution yes i know
few years ago i i do understand what
you're saying there but but at least the
reference to the case would be uh needed
right yes um
it's the
you want the whole lot in a high court
well i i i i go back to what i said a
moment ago um
mr gardner
you've not raised this at all before
have you
th this is yet again something that you
could quite easily have put into the
inquiry
as part of any evidence you wanted to
put in any statement at a much earlier
date and then i wouldn't have to be
asking you
to read out a reference number because
i'd have that document in front of me
not only that though the council and the
appellant would have that document in
front of them and they could have given
due consideration
to the evidence that you're putting
forward it really is not acceptable to
be springing things out of the hat
at the last minute
um even though someone's lice could be
affected that's that's not that's not
the point um
with due respect mr gardner the the the
inquiry process has been set up for many
months
parties have in the main
stuck to the
requirement to submit the evidence at
the appropriate time i've been flexible
in that i've allowed interested parties
to put forward evidence at a later time
but you can't you can't just spring
fresh evidence on a witness whilst
they're actually on the witness stand
that they've never seen before
okay then we'll that will if anything
happens that will be directed to the
builder in the near future and claims
uh
one more question
i'm asking
how do you
a fit uh in reality error
safe other models are the 100
safe that you're using
sorry say the question again i didn't
right the models that you're using right
against reality
how effective are they how safe are they
are they 100 percent safe
all i say is that the death of
recognized dispersion model has been
used
there's a depth of recognized
dispersion model
i don't really understand what you what
you're trying to ask me
well you're doing a model
of pollution
is that hundred percent safe
in reality
either yes or no all i say is
the model's verified against local
monitoring data so it's as accurate as
it as it can't be
okay another way to pull it is it
accurate
well it's been verified and adjusted
accordingly
as i set out in both reports in the
verification process
so you're only going on
what you're being told or what you've
seen it differ
is that correct
i'm going based upon the
approach but
annual air quality state status report
what's been reported
okay then that's all i've got to ask
okay thank you
[Applause]
okay well thank you mr grubb i've not
been
informed that anyone else wish to put
any questions to you so miss reed
just a couple of questions in
re-examination mr grub just to clear up
a few points please can you turn up the
addendum air quality assessment
can you just give me the core document
oh sorry so yeah core document 2.1
go with me please
seconds
good
oh sorry
yeah i have it thank you thank you do
you have that mr grub yes right i just
want to clear up a couple of points with
you if i may
um it was put to you that um the um
amber that the
just bear with me a second let me get
the exact question you're asked a number
of questions um about um
yes the ambulance sutton road um
monitoring location and it was put to
you that you won't get the same
concentrations there as you would at the
receptor points outside the school in
the nursery you unders you recall those
questions
yeah and what you said was well it's
within an acceptable distance to verify
the air quality dispersion model now
just pausing there
can you just please explain
how
how the concentrations in the model in
respect of the receptor locations were
derived and then how
the readings from the amberlin sutton
road junction are used to verify the
model so the distinction between the two
stages of the assessment please
so
the initial process is to verify your
model against known concentrations
i.e the ambulance sutton road
diffusion tube location
so you actually put
your traffic in your model consider
other elements on top of that
then you run your model
um
you get your concentration out
and then you compare that with the
in this case in the dental with the we
did 2019 traffic blows and we did too
far against 2019 air quality
concentrations
um
and then if if it's not with an
exceptional level of tolerance as in the
verification is within
ideally you want to be within 10 to 10
but if you're not you're a lot
you're allowed to do an adjustment
factor
so then
once you've got your adjustment factor
you re-verify to make sure that you
you're correlating with the air quality
concentration at the oven in sutton road
and if you are you then run your
scenarios
and then once you run
your scenarios on the receptor locations
you adjust the output of the model by
this adjustment factor you've derived
due to the verification
then you and then you do a few
calculations to get your overall quantum
of concentration at that receptor point
okay if you turn up please paragraph 2.1
paragraph 2.1
of the air quality
assessment
addendum on page two
yeah
what
we can what is the input information
what is the input information that is
used to calculate the pollution
concentration
in respect to the specified areas that
have been considered
so you uh input
highway width average speeds
types of vehicles and
ie cars
lgbs and
hdvs and then you put in uh
meteorological conditions which we used
um
south end airport was just you know all
this was agreed with the local the
environmental health officer at the
local authority
okay
next point it was put to you that well
um there have been a number of occasions
i think three
uh where um there have been exceedances
at the amblin um sutton roundabout
junction
and we can see those can we at page 10
of the air quality
assessment addendum paragraph 3.2
yes right
then if we look at the baseline air
quality modeled results
for the receptor locations
we can see that those have been assessed
in terms of the 2019 baseline at page 11
and also at page 14 in respect of the
2029
um baseline you see that based on
concentrations
um in respect of the modeled
concentrations at receptors
11 12 and 13 which are those outside the
relevant schools and day nurseries
is there
is there
an exceedance of the annual mean
objectives
in relation first to nitrogen dioxide
no no
and if we then look at
the operational impacts
the operational impact we have those at
pages 16
through to uh
19
of the air quality assessment addendum
um first point
first point
um in respect of nitrogen dioxide um do
the predicted development
impacts lead to exceedances at those or
any other receptor points
no
and in respect of the percentage change
in respect to the percentage change in
the impact descriptor is there above a
negligible impact in respect of any of
those assessment locations
no all negative no
and in respect of pm
2.5 and pm
10
pm 2.5 and pm 10 it was put too well
those um
those are effectively i think mr gardner
said guess work in terms of how those
have been considered can you please have
a look at
paragraph 3.4 of the air quality
assessment addendum
page 10.
yeah
and
in respect of um in respect of pm10 pm
2.5
uh where
where do the estimates
in respect to background air pollution
data come from mr grubb
right and
thank you and defra death for data what
weight should be given to that
data in the assessment process
it's a standard
methodology to use different background
much thank you standard methodology to
use deaf for background maps
and if we then look at the
um
the
annual mean concentrations
in respect to the background levels for
pm 10 and pm 2.5
do any of those exceed the relevant
objectives mr grubb
no no
and then if we look over the page please
over the page
to
uh
just bear with me a second yeah page
page 11 sorry page 17
table 4.2 and 4.3
where we have the predicted development
impact
on the annual mean pm 2.5 and pm 10
concentrations post development do any
of those exceed the relevant objectives
mr grub
no no
and in terms of the impact descriptor is
there an impact at any of the relevant
receptor locations
that exceeds negligible
no all negative no
and it was put to you by mr foster that
well you haven't measured it you can't
know you can't know
and you said well no but in terms of the
modeling and the verification process
that you have undertaken
that you have set out clearly is in
accordance with deaf or guidance
what confidence
can one have
in the modeled outputs
it's a high level of confidence high
level of confidence thank you very much
and then just to
just to conclude then please um do you
have a copy of the planning statement of
common ground in front of you if not
i'll just read out the relevant point
um
okay well let me read it out just to
speed matters up and so um it's for your
note it's paragraph 5.23
oh sorry just before i go to that just
just one one other point please you
asked a number of um questions about
construction traffic
um just just to be clear in respect of
construction um traffic um are you aware
of the condition where there will be a
construction management plan
mr grubb
i'm not aware of it but that is a
standard approach it's a standard
approach thank you very much and then if
we um consider what the local planning
authority's response has been and as set
out in the statements of common ground
it's paragraph 5.23.1
i'll just read it it is agreed that the
appeal site does not lie within or close
to a designated air quality management
area and that the impacts from vehicle
emissions that would result from the
proposed development will be
negligible it is agreed that the air
quality pollutant concentrations would
remain well below
well below their respective air quality
objectives and targets and therefore no
mitigation
is required
any difference between you
and the expert
statutory consultant the environmental
health and the local planning authority
in respect of air quality matters and
the robustness of the model that's
before the inquiry mr grove
we're both
in agreement in agreement thank you very
much thank you sir i don't have any
further questions
thank you
okay thank you miss reed thank you
mr grubb
this concludes this part of the
inquiry so we can we can end the the
team's
session i think now and we'll have a
mid-morning break
so that we can
move on with mr
hycroft so i make it 11 48
if we
got a few things to
close and move about so if we go into is
five past enough time for everyone
let's try that can we so i'll adjourn
now and we'll resume at 1205 we'll also
review then progress and where we might
be going with the rest of the inquiry so
i'll adjourn now and resume at 1205.
thank you
well the inquiry is resumed ladies and
gentlemen
um misread and mr parkinson and of
course mr foster can i just have
some thoughts as to
progress um obviously we're a bit later
through the day
than i thought we might be when starting
mr pycroft's evidence
um are there any restrictions on the
availability of this room later today
yeah
what about participants is there anyone
else
anyone who
basically uh as as ought to be apparent
i'm envisioning that we might have to be
sitting a bit later tonight to get
through all the business
yes
is that me no if it helps um i think i
indicated last week that
um in light of the evidence and the fact
that mr pike was not
as far as i'm aware covering highways
matters um
uh i i may well be in a situation where
we put all our highways points to mr
blair and there's no questions left over
for mr pycroft so it might be as far as
the council's involvement is concerned
and that would be fairly quick if at all
okay yes i mean you you'd get you've
given an hour estimate for mr gascoigne
obviously
by croft is
subsuming mr gascoigne's evidence as it
were yeah i've obviously taken
into account the evidence given by
mr blair and councillor shaw and in
light of that and
what questions we would have mr hycroft
um so i think the our estimate was at
the beginning of the inquiry and you
know obviously if things move on in
different ways yeah okay well we'll see
how it is but that's that's helpful to
know because that that may well shorten
what what um what i was envisioning we
could be working too and so equally from
my point of view um what i propose to do
to speed matters up and given the large
degree of agreement with the points
which i put to council ashore
is i'm possibly going to be putting
points in relatively broad
terms without going to each individual
document again because you have the
references from my cross-examination et
cetera i mean mr pycroff will obviously
take us to the documents if he wishes to
but again hopefully that will assist us
just in terms of moving through matters
okay let's let's move on
mr foster um yeah there were um two or
three questions from last week which
would have gone to mr gascoigne that i
think would deferred we'll pick those up
uh i'm guessing probably an hour yeah
any restriction i've got is i probably
need to be out of here by about 5 30.
okay well let's
as i say the longer we we we spend
talking about how long we're going to be
we're we're cutting into the time aren't
we so i don't want to do that any more
than necessary but it's helpful what
you've told me all so far so
on that note let's move on so miss reed
would you like to introduce your witness
please
thank you sir um mr pycroft you are now
giving evidence both in respect of
planning matters um and in respect of
housing land supply matters um in
respect of your background and
qualifications though we can find that
in the proof of evidence relating to
housing land supply matters
and it's set out at page one of that
document so i'll just introduce you to
the inquiry uh you are ben pycroft you
have a ba honours and postgraduate
diploma in town planning from the
university of newcastle and you're a
member of the rtpi you are a director of
emory planning is that correct that's
correct
can everyone hear me is that yeah is
that okay a bit i think maybe just bring
it a little bit closer a bit closer with
the mic might be helpful is that better
well it is fine for me because because
you're facing me but it's really those
at the back of the room but yes i'm
getting thumbs up so yeah okay thank you
good
um and you
uh
you
set out your duty to the inquiry at
paragraph 1.5 can you just um please
read that
i understand my duties to the inquiry
and i have complied and will continue to
comply with that duty i confirm that
this evidence identifies all facts which
i regard as being relevant to the
opinion that i have expressed and that
the inquiry's attention has been drawn
to any matter which would affect the
validity of that opinion i believe that
the facts stated within this proof are
true and that the opinions expressed are
correct and comprise my true
professional opinions which are
expressed irrespective of by whom i am
instructed thank you now that was
obviously in respect of the
housing land supply proof of evidence
that was produced
the proof of evidence was written by mr
gascoigne who can't be here
um have you had an opportunity to
consider that proof of evidence mr
pycroff i have yes and just to be clear
um
do you
adopt the conclusions of it or are the
points that we need to turn to a little
bit later where you perhaps differ a
little bit from mr gascoigne yes the the
only difference sir is um towards the
end of the proof in terms of the the
weight given to different benefits um
which i can
explain in my in my chief other than
that then yes i adopt the uh the proof
and its content and just to be clear you
apply the same principles that you just
read out in the statement of truth do
you to the planning evidence
correct yes and did you have the
opportunity to visit the site mr pycroft
um prior to um
well prior to today and giving evidence
i have yes yeah good thank you very much
um good okay now i'm going to start with
the core strategy please
and you'll recall from and i'm not going
to go to um all of the points again
in terms of the
uh
in terms of the paragraph references
within the core strategy but you'll
you'll recall from
examination and sorry cross-examination
with council ashore that it was agreed
that the district's heavily constrained
by greenbelt ecology and also traffic
across the district um how how does the
um core strategy plan to deliver growth
in that in that context
yes so
essentially as you you quite likely
point out and and council assure
accepted that the the district is
constrained by environmental and
planning constraints um
and as well as traffic and what the core
strategy does to
address that is it identifies a
settlement hierarchy of which rochefort
stroke ashington is at the top of that
hierarchy and seeks to locate new
development including new residential
development towards um or in align with
that settlement hierarchy
okay
um and we know that um policy h3 policy
h3 um sets out
a requirement for approximately 500
homes
on the site
we referred in cross-examination of
councillor short the cogent land
decision that's been produced by the
rule 6 party
um to what extent is it relevant that
the council and inspector were aware of
the constraints on the highway network
generally which we've seen through the
core strategy and specifically in
respect of ashington and rochford um
when um when um making the allocation um
in respect to the appeal side
yeah well it's highly relevant that
these issues or the issues that have
come up in the in the course of this
appeal were already considered at the
time that the um core strategy was
firstly being developed consulted on um
with engagement with the with the with
the public um across
the district
and also for the inspector
and ultimately
whilst those um issues were around at
the time the the the
uh site was still uh allocated to meet
housing needs because again
to do with the the settlement hierarchy
and
locating new residential development in
sustainable locations
and what what to what extent does the
the fact that the concerns particularly
in respect of the
um hall street junction and the railway
bridge to what extent
does the fact that those concerns were
known about at the time that the
allocation
was made say about the appropriateness
of providing this quantum of
residential development in principle on
the appeal side yeah it it says that
because those concerns were known and
specific issues around
that junction were known um that that
was taken into account by those
preparing the plan and also those or the
inspector examining the plan and
ultimately finding it sound for adoption
good um and
you'll recall and we might we you might
want to go to this but policy h3 makes
reference to appendix h1
and policy clt
1
in respect to the infrastructure
requirements um for the appeal site and
there was agreement with councillor shaw
that all of those had been complied with
in this case again what does that say
about the appropriateness of bringing
the site forward for residential
development yeah it says it's
appropriate to bring the site forward
because um as you point out and and
councillor shaw agreed that the policy
itself directs um you to the appendix
and also the policy clc one which is to
do with the
planning obligations
and essentially links in which
infrastructure and other improvements
are required for that site to come
forward so by meeting that the criteria
set out in that list it is appropriate
for the site to to come forward in
accordance with the core strategy
and what weight should be given to the
package of sustainability benefits i'm
just going a little bit out of turn here
but in that context we at the time the
core strategy was adopted the
constraints in respect to the railway
bridge were known the strategy was to
direct growth to the top tier
settlements
because those were considered to be the
most sustainable locations to growth how
relevant and what weight should then be
given to the package of sustainability
measures that are proposed by the
appellant here having regard to the
core strategy and the policies within it
yeah it's um it's highly relevant
because it's it was it's in complete
accordance with the the strategy that's
that's set out in the in the core
strategy in the development plan
and in terms of the weight to be given
to its significant weight because that
is in in line with the
uh approach taken and also
uh broadly and then also specifically
for this site because of of the um the
measure the bullet point list in the uh
the appendix h1
um and
given that those infrastructure
requirements in policy h1 are complied
with and given that the council does not
take any issue because it agrees that
the proposal is in compliance with
policy clt-1 for example with the
package of sustainability measures that
are proposed here
what weight in the planning balance and
again i'm just jumping ahead a little
bit should be given what weight in the
planning balance should be given to any
residual known impacts
at the hall street
sorry at the at the um
whole street junction yeah it's it's
limited weight to those impacts because
um of the reasons set out in the core
strategy and indeed the cogent land the
case that actually these issues were
known about
the the measures to address it were set
out in the appendix h1
um with with a link through to the
policy clt one
and then therefore by meeting those
appropriate improvements that i set out
in the in the appendix um
bearing in mind that any issues that
whole road were known about when the
plan was adopted
means that that those impacts are
reduced in the overall balance
thank you
um
and um just just sort of moving on from
that then um in terms of h3 given
compliance with the terms of it which
was agreed by councillor shaw what is
the planned strategy for the release of
the appeal site over the plan period
yeah so the the the strategy sets out uh
in this policy um proposed residential
extensions to
uh residential envelopes post 2021 of
course we are post 2021 so the core
strategy envisaged this site to be
actually under construction by now if
you if you look at the uh the trajectory
it fully anticipated that this
development would be coming forward to
meet the housing needs that it had
identified at the time
thank you
and then
what that policy tells us is that the
location and quantum of growth is to be
determined through the allocations plan
um and obviously the allocations plan
has to be in conformity with the core
strategy and general conformity with the
court strategy
now in respect to the allocations plan
that's where we see the allocation scr
eight
and um there are two bullet points
two bullet points
in scr8
that indicate
effectively where more than four 500
homes can be provided on the site
council ashore accepted that we are here
in compliance with those two bullet
points i.e the criteria in them are met
your position please in respect of that
mr pie craft yeah so um you write the um
paragraph
3.227 page 72
of cd 6.2 um
that we're referring to and it sets out
two bullet points um
whereby the minimum housing requirement
that has been set out in the core
strategy could be exceeded the first is
where there is uh the need to
maintain a five-year housing land supply
and obviously it's common ground here
that firstly the council can't
demonstrate a five-year housing land
supply but also i think
importantly that this site would remedy
that and assist the council in
maintaining a five-year housing loan
supply going forward
and the second bullet point is in
reference to
compensate for a shortfall
of dwellings that had been projected to
be delivered within the location
and you recall sir that in the uh in my
proof as in the proof with my my name on
the on the front of it i've set out the
trajectory and how housing completions
have
fared with that and then gone into
explaining this specific location i.e
the the the rochford-washington location
where sites have
um fallen behind that trajectory meaning
that we've we've hit that bullet point
as well
in fact when i was looking back through
my proof i realized that whilst i'd
referred to the appeal science and the
west rochefort site
um i had in
in that context referred to the
brownfield site at stanbridge mills
and you'll see sir in the housing
statement of common ground that that
site is also slipped so beyond the plan
period now there's no expectation but it
it further um justifies the compliance
with this bullet point because there are
clearly sites that haven't proceeded in
the location
in accordance with the trajectory
meaning
um that that was coming forward for more
uh units now is in compliance with that
and as as you said miss reed um
councillor shaw agreed last thursday
and what do those bullet points tell us
if anything about the importance to
deliver housing on the appeal site in
the circumstances in which we now find
ourselves i.e no five-year housing land
supply
and other sites that are allocated in
the plan have slipped in respect of the
trajectory yeah absolutely it's very
important for the site the left you know
that those allocations left of which i
think we're the the last
um settlement extension site left to
come forward to meet those needs that
were identified throughout the
development plan so that's the core
strategy and the
and the allocations plan to to pick up
the slippage from others
and again just jumping ahead a little
bit given the constraints in the
district given the constraints in the
district what opportunities are there
elsewhere to make up that slippage for
example through windfall developments in
this district having regard to for
example the green belt constraints well
it's really limited
very limited not not least because of
the constraints but also obviously in
preparing my proof and agreeing the
housing statement of common ground
with the council and the windfall sites
just
have not been identified that the
overall trajectory looks at schla site
strategic housing land availability
assessment sites and they're few and far
between as you could imagine given um
where the plan is up to and also the
fact that
um when this was looked at at the time
of the course strategy they needed
greenbelt release to meet the needs um
both up to 2021 and and beyond
okay
um and then we have
i'm just going to turn it at myself just
bear with me a second
um
so core document 6.2 ser 8
and
then we have
at
3.6
yeah
3.243 through to 3.248
we have the highways requirements of
that policy
and we also see some points in respect
of site capacity at 3.224
um
councillor shaw agreed that we were in
compliance with those paragraphs just
first general point d do you agree with
that i do yeah i recall the exchange
between you and i i agree with what um
the counsellor agreed on on thursday
thank you
second point um paragraph 3.248
and also
paragraph 3.224
which are talking about actions to
address the impacts of the scheme
are those new requirements mr piecroft
or is there a cross-reference back to
the
provisions of the core strategy policy
we've just looked at there no they're
not new requirements it's
cross-referring back to the appendix um
well it's cross-referring back to policy
h3 and within h3 to the the the appendix
h1 and and one can see that at 3.224
that the bulleted list on page 71 of um
of the uh allocations plan uh mirrors
mirrors that set out in the core
strategy
so again
um agreed that there is compliance uh
with um those parts of that policy your
position then please taking all of that
into account as to whether there is
compliance
with policy h3 and ser eight here
yes there's full compliance with those
two policies yeah
and um
councillor shaw's position was that full
weight should be given at the compliance
with the development those development
plan policies
here or sorry full weight to the
development plan policies here and she
accepted compliance with those policies
also
um your position please as to the weight
that should be attributed to compliance
with those development plan policies
please yeah i agree with them councillor
shaw fellow in her
uh oh or
i agree with council shaw's answers
there that full weight should be given
to the compliance with those um policies
uh and then we have um policy t1 and dm
um 31.
and just looking at policy t1 please
policy t1
um and um we we
that's on page
zero 107 call document 6.2
i've got that thank you and um first
first sentence there agreed compliance
with this and by the local planning
authority
developments will be required to be
located and designed in such a way so as
to reduce reliance on the private car
now it's agreed that there's compliance
with
well all the policy but this part of the
policy but in view of the overall
strategy
that's set out within the development
plan
what weight should be given to the
compliance with firstly that part of the
policy
yeah it should be um it should be
significant way because
again it ties back into
some of my earlier answers and those of
council shaw last week where
actually the the strategy set seeks to
locate development including residential
development in sustainable locations so
where it says um in the first sentence
development will be required to be
located
and designed in such a ways to reduce
reliance on the private car that speaks
to the overall strategy and approach
that was adopted in the in the plan and
in respect of the appeals site
specifically
any dispute between the appellant the
highway authority and now the local
planning authority's evidence given
through council ashore
as to the sustainability of the appeal
site
uh no there's no d um uh difference
between us and indeed it was in the
um
planning statement of common ground in
terms of its accessibility credentials
and i think also there's a point in the
state of common ground with the highway
authority also isn't there that there is
yeah and in fact throughout the
throughout the evidence um both risen
and normal yeah
and um next part of that policy
we see
however some impact on the highway
network is inevitable
and the council will work with the
developers and highway authority to
ensure that appropriate improvements are
carried out the council will seek
developer contributions where necessary
and councillor shaw agreed that
um
those
that that part of the policy was also
complied with having regard to reading
the development plan as a whole and the
compliance with scr8 and h3 that we've
we've just looked at do you agree with
that mr piper i i do yeah it's probably
worth
remembering that the policies in the
plan
would apply to
different developments but where you've
got an allocation that's specifically
listed in an earlier policy and the list
of uh improvements that are to be seen
with it in its appendix i.e the appendix
h1
this policy speaks to those allocations
for those um directly to that specific
um list in the plan
and in that context where those
where those um
specific improvements that are set out
within the allocation policies and with
which council assure agreed
the appeal scheme would deliver where
those are delivered what impact should
be given sorry what weight should be
given to any residual impacts on the
highway network having regard to policy
t1 well it should be limited weight
because the policy firstly identifies
that that there will be some impacts on
the highway network or rather some
impacts on the highway network would be
inevitable um but goes on to say well
you know there would be appropriate
improvements uh that needs to be carried
out and linked against the developer
contributions so in our case because
we've identified in policy h3 with its
appendix and cross-reference to the
planning obligations policy um we're in
accordance with the the policy and
therefore any impacts would be given
limited weights
and just um in respect of the agreed
position with councillor shaw um that
relates to policy t1 and similar points
made in respect of policy dm 31 agreed
compliance with that policy um your
position please as to what weight should
be given to the agreed compliance with
the development plan as a whole yeah it
should be very significant because the
plan as we as we've established
looks to locate sites in sustainable
locations and in the highest tier of
which we're in
then goes through and identifies how it
would come forward and then and then as
a result there has to be compliance with
the other policies in the plan otherwise
there'd be a bizarre tension which would
mean that the allocations couldn't come
forward and back to the points made in
opening and throughout mr gascoigne's
proof about
how we're obviously in a plan led system
and and therefore
a site coming forward in accordance with
the development plan both in terms of
its allocation but also the application
of policies
means that it should be afforded very
significant weights
and i just want to be clear about where
your scale is because all planning
witnesses that i seem to cross-examine
or examine in chief have different
scales in terms of benefits
it very significant
in your scale mr pycroft is there
anything above very significant or is
that the top of the scale there's not
that's the top
good and um
just to be clear
in
giving very significant weight to
bringing a site forward in accordance
with the plan led system
would there have been community
engagement and a process for concerns to
be taken into account in the balance
that the plan struck
um through it through the adoption um of
the of the plan absolutely yeah i mean
it's a fundamental core uh of the
planning system that um communities and
stakeholders are engaged in the process
uh at the early stage and the course
strategy we probably don't need to turn
to it now but
the
earlier sections of the course strategy
talk you through that process through
issues and options and preferred options
are revised preferred options um through
to submission plan um perhaps someone's
more familiar than others but but but
the point being that there's plenty of
opportunity for communities to to engage
and indeed will have engaged and voiced
their concerns or
or otherwise through those processes
and i think the it was agreed by council
ashore that the core strategy itself
um sets out that the
overall distribution of growth was said
to be a balanced and fair strategy you
recall those words in there
it yeah i recall those uh words and and
it reflects the wording in the core
strategy and what it's getting at is
predominantly location in the top tier
of settlements
and some sites allocated in the in the
tiers below that um to avoid um
effectively large-scale um development
in the
outlying villages where where they're
traditionally less sustainable
and is that of an approach that's
consistent or inconsistent with the
framework mr pycroft
it's it's fully consistent it's
absolutely consistent with the framework
which talks of a plan led system
and community engagement throughout
um now i want to have a think about the
consequences of not bringing forward the
allocation in accordance with the
plan-led system
um and so if you just put put aside the
development plan and take out the
housing statements of common ground
please
give me a moment while i locate that
is this the housing supply and delivery
juan yes thank you sir
okay now just a point of clarification
before we look at consequences
um you'll recall from the evidence given
by the rule six party that there was a
comment
that the leader of the council had said
that housing targets had been met
in the last three years by the council
can you turn up page six of the
statements of common ground please i
just want to be clear as to what the
evidence is in this respect yes i've got
that thank you
sorry what was the page again page six
absolutely and it's table three
and now first first point mr piecroft
um what we're looking at here
is the housing requirement in the plan
the 250 dwellings per annum figure
that's correct
has that figure increased stayed the
same or decreased following the
introduction of the government's
standard methodology oh it's
significantly increased it's now 362
dwellings per year rather than the much
lower figure of 250 in the plan
at second point
we can see um
at the table
at the table that from i think 2017
2018
uh there has been an exceedance of the
core strategy figure
has there been an exceedance of the lhn
figure no
no it's not because you can see that
that um
all those figures that you've that
you've just taken us to there uh are
below the 362.
at third point in respect of this point
that was
said to be put by the leader what is the
cumulative
over or under provision
against
even the lower 250 figure from the core
strategy
so it's in the fourth column there and
the um
and fifth column there and the
cumulative under provision in this
authority is 829 dwellings
even against the lower adopted housing
requirement figure in the plan rather
than the the actual local housing need
thank you uh and um
if we
yeah if we then turn up please the
position
in respect of five-year housing land
supply
which is at page ten
what is the agreed position
in respect of the
council's five-year housing land supply
and page 11.
please yep so the agreed position is
against the local housing need
and a five percent buffer
the deliverable five-year housing land
supply extends to
1537 units over the period to 31st of
march 2026
and that equates to
an equivalent of 4.04 years
which is row e of the table eight
and a shortfall of 364 dwellings
in row f
so just to summarize and is the council
meeting the minimum requirements of
national policy
mr pycroft no it's not there's a
significant shortfall against its
five-year housing right requirement plus
buffer
and
we can see we can see
showed me a second
we can see at what what's the position
in respect of
future supply please paragraphs 2.26 and
2.27
yeah it's um
bleak because
the
council's housing trajectory which
probably don't need to turn up for your
reference sir it's cd 8.04
or 8.04 correct yeah
um the trajectory doesn't stop at the
end of the five year period but it goes
on for another five years
to to the end of 2031
and
even including 500 dwellings at the
appeal site
those um schla sites that i refer to
previously
brownfield sites
that are allocated in the plan
so i referred to um previously as well
uh you can see that there is a there
would still be a be a shortfall
um
of
409 dwellings in the next five-year
period
which is expressed in paragraph 2.27 of
this statement of common ground
and without the inclusion of the appeal
site what would the shortfall increase
to well it increases to 909 and that
that again is assuming that all of those
brownfield sites that have
i say all um the few brownfield sites
that we know
exist in either the allocations plan or
the schla
come forward and obviously there's no
certainty that they would but
even with those coming forward there
would be
a significant shortfall against local
housing need going forward
okay
and um
yeah just just in resp just one point of
clarification because i think there is a
distinction
in the statement of common ground and mr
gascoigne's evidence so the statement of
common ground
records significant weight to the
provision of generally of housing
in the tilts of balance
i think mr gascoigne at one point says
very significant weight what what weight
do you give to the provision generally
of housing in these circumstances i
adopt the position in the the sign
statement of common ground so it's
significant weight to housing generally
as recorded in uh paragraph 2.25 of this
statement of common ground
and just to be clear just to be clear
you give and it's agreed that the
position in respect of affordable
housing affordable housing should be
given very significant weight which is
right at the top of your scale can we
just turn up please the parts of the
statements of common ground
dealing with affordable housing
uh which we see starts at page seven
yeah i've got that thank you
how significant
is the affordable housing need in this
authority mr pycroft well it's it's very
significant um because what one can see
on on this table
uh and this section of the statement of
common ground i think it was picked up
with councillor shaw on thursday
um that actually the affordable housing
completions over the entire plan period
today have only averaged 26 per year
and when that is compared to the
need identified in the core strategy
of 131
affordable homes per year
what one can see a significant shortfall
against that need of over 1600 units
1603
units over the period
which is what which which is why in my
view
the weight to be afforded to affordable
housing should be higher than even
higher than the general uh housing so it
goes up a notch to to the very
significant due to
serious on delivery
against um against need in the plan
and then also as this statement of
common ground explains against the
actual need that's been identified in
the latest strategic housing markets
assessment
and we saw with councillor shaw we saw
with councillor shaw
um that the
figures that are given in the core
strategy in respect of the housing
waiting list
have increased as compared to the
information that's given
in the emerging strategic options
document
and that the affordable housing position
in this district is characterized as one
of the worst in the country
how appropriate is it therefore how
appropriate is it
um to ascribe weight at the top of the
scale mr pycroft to affordable housing
delivery yes it's it's very appropriate
to do so
given those needs given the status
that that the
spatial options plan
explains where the where the authority
sits in terms of affordability in the
country and the and the increased
waiting list and
i can't remember the page number but
it's cd
6.4 is the spatial options paper
um just for your reference
i think sorry if i can just elaborate a
little bit further we
can quite often get lost in the numbers
but
these are real people on the waiting
list that need homes now
and what is the prospect of those homes
being provided given the remaining
capacity in allocations
and the constraints across the district
that you have identified
what is the prospect
of that happening well there's a limited
prospect and
of that of those needs being met by
existing sites and and you can see that
in the statement of common ground myself
and the
planning policy officer worked on a
schedule of sites that could
realistically be expected to deliver
affordable homes over the next five
years and
um that comes out as as 471
which is in appendix one of the
statement of common ground
compared to a need of um
238 per year as set out in the shema
so less than less than two years worth
of need has been identified in the
pipeline
and of course that that figure has to
deal both with both mostly both with the
newly arising need and also with the
existing shortfall yeah that's just the
that's just the need um
that's just the need going forward if if
one adds the the shortfall on as i've
done in my
proof of evidence
which is table 6.2 on on page 25.
and and you'll see sir on there
what i've done is i've i've set up what
the
affordable housing need
identified in the shemas
how many
uh completions have taken place within
the the period that the shema looks at
what the supply is that myself and the
the council have agreed going forward
and identified a shortfall at 2026 of to
2325 affordable homes
uh is the new plan come is a new plan
coming to the rescue anytime soon mr
piecroft in this authority
no it's not it's at an early stage in
its production
and as recorded in the planning
statement of common ground therefore
carries
limited weight
so limited play weight to any particular
policy choices in the emerging strategic
option but uh document
but councillor shaw accepted that
whatever option is
pursued
it's going to
include or it's going to need to include
existing allocations um is that right
and can you just talk us through
what the strategic options document
says in that respect yes i can if i can
just turn it up its core document 6.4
and this is the
spatial options consultation paper 2021.
and just for the first reference point
within this um page five explains that
the consultation ran
for six weeks
up until the end of september or 22nd of
september 2021
and i raised that because that so was
obviously after the committee meeting
for this
appeal
but one when one looks at the four
options that are put forward within this
plan
options two three and four all build on
the first option
and the first option
is to effectively exhaust
all of the housing supply
within its existing settlement
boundaries
so that includes any
windfall brownfield sites but it also
includes
allocations that have not yet come
forward
including this site
so when one looks at option
strategy option one
and i'm on page
53
and over the page on 54
it explains that 4 200 homes
have been identified
and that says that includes existing
planned housing developments
including sites with planning permission
sites allocated in our current plan and
other urban developments
so therefore this site has already been
included within
spatial sorry strategy option one
but because the 4200 doesn't meet the
local housing need in full over the
emerging plan period
which for your reference is 7 200 units
the other options then go on to work out
how that shortfall
would be would be addressed
and you'll see sir in those other three
options
it's option one plus green belt release
in
various uh with various different
options as to where and and why that
that would take place
and is that approach that seeks to
maximize non-green belt
release
prior to looking to greenbelt release
consistent with the framework yes it's
consistent with the framework and
councillor shaw agreed in those
circumstances
that it was inevitable that the appeal
site needed to come forward to meet the
critical housing needs of the district
do you agree with that mr pycroft i do
yes
she did say that and i agree with that
yeah
and points were put to
mr blair
in cross-examination
um
that
well and it's page one two four
this document recognizes that there are
issues
in respect of
road connectivity
yeah it does yeah um
but nevertheless
continues to envisage that in any
scenario the appeal site is going to
need to come forward
to meet the critical housing needs
of the district
that's correct yeah
and um in those circumstances
in those
circumstances um what weight should be
attributed to the agreed position
between you
and council ashore for the local
planning authority
that that it is inevitable that the
appeal side needs to come forward to
meet the critical housing needs of the
district yeah significant weight the
site's clearly relied on
both within its current plan but also
its emerging plan
under any option
and then we see this at the bottom of
page one two four
uh a comment that a strategy based
solely around the private car is likely
to simply reinforce current strengths
and trends and we must put in place
complementary measures that deliver a
modal shift in both existing
and new communities towards sustainable
options wherever possible
again what weight do you give
to the package of sustainability
measures
put forward by the appellant here having
regard to those comments in the emerging
plan
as well as the existing plan yeah
significant weight because the
sustainable measures will assist
um
in terms of the
development site or the appeal site
itself
and also
the the
the wider area
and is completely in line with how the
emerging plan
sees new development coming forward
is an approach that appears to have been
promoted at various points through this
inquiry that while
sustainable
efforts to improve sustainable transport
options and to encourage modal shift
might not work
is that an approach that is consistent
with either the development plan
the emerging plan or the framework no
it's inconsistent with all three because
you can see when looking through those
documents so that's a a core objective
of both the development plan in its
existing form and emerging format and
the um the objectives of the framework
thank you
and so just
pulling all that together
having regard to the
housing need
both affordable and general that you
have identified and it's agreed in the
statement of common ground
what would the consequences be
of not allowing the appeal site to come
forward in accordance with the
allocation well it wouldn't meet those
critical housing needs and that have
been identified in the plan and it
wouldn't um comply with the strategy
that's all also been set out in the
development plan
good um in terms of um
yeah in terms of uh
third party concerns you have a
section in your appendices where you
deal with those i'm not going to ask you
to read all of them out because
aware of time constraints and they are
committed to writing but there's a table
isn't there i think it's appendix just
for the inspectors note
uh yes it's appendix ii
of the the planning proof of evidence
yes correct yeah okay so just
just a reference it is and it also cross
references to the planning statement of
common ground
um as well there's i'm just going to
pause you there appendix 2 to the what
the hell i'm so sorry the planning
statement of common ground
sorry appendix 2 of mr gascoigne's proof
of evidence appendix 2 to mr gascoigne's
proof
yeah okay
i've got that one and you say that cross
references to the planning statement of
common ground
it does say so sorry just just before
you do just rather confusingly sir when
you open up appendix too it's got a
heading saying appendix one but it's
under the top of pentax too yeah it's
under the tab appendix 2. it's under the
tab for appendix 2 and it's got the
heading other material site specific
policy considerations
and then it deals with various points
that have been raised by third parties
and sorry you wanted to refer to the
planning statement of common ground
sorry i was just going to say that
actually in section 5
of the planning statement of common
ground
which is matters on which the parties
agree so that's the appellants and the
local planning authority
you you'll see sir that some of these
headings that are in the appendix to mr
gascoigne's proof also
mirror and marry up to what's in the
planning statement and common ground
and any dispute other than in respect of
highways matters that have been
discussed at length any dispute by the
lpa
that the
impacts any other impacts of the scheme
can be adequately accommodated subject
conditions and 106 obligation no that's
the agreed position
um
yeah now just just a point uh raised by
the mp in respect of an appeal decision
i think it was the
raymond
secretary of state appeal decision
and don't need to go to it in detail
but firstly um was that a proposal that
was in compliance with the development
plan uh no it wasn't it was contrary to
the uh the
medway council development plan
second point um
were there um
landscape issues that were of concern in
that case
what was the position uh there were
there was um
the
there was a um a difference between the
two parties there that whether there was
a significant impact on character and
appearance uh through landscape and
visual appraisal
uh and um
a third point you'll recall i asked mr
blair about so i'm not going to ask you
about but
um his evidence was that well there were
effectively two models that were being
uh his evidence was that there were two
models
um
one used by the local planning authority
and then one by the appellate there was
a dispute about which one of them was
the appropriate model i'm not going to
ask you about the highways parts of that
decision because it's not for your
evidence
but taking all of those points into
consideration are there material
differences
as between the case before this
inspector
and that appeal decision yes there are
material differences between
that decision and and the um
the the case here
and what weight do you give to that
appeal decision taking into account
those differences a limited way when
when the appeals read in full including
the inspectors report
good uh benefits
um
now
just bear with me can i just check
progress we've just got to one o'clock
obviously we we want to finish mr pie
crafting chief
we're nearly there sir probably no more
than about 10 minutes okay let's let's
aim for no later than stay quarter past
if we can um so it benefits um mr
pycroft and um
we have
your position in respect of
you've already given in respect to new
housing in general you've said
significant correct yeah correct uh your
position in respect of affordable
housing you've already confirmed
very significant weight
um position please um
in respect of the community building now
um
i've seen mr gascoigne actually
describes this as
moderate to significance at one point
that's his 12.20 but then significant
later
at 12.28 to 12.30
uh councillor shaw gives it significant
weight your position please in respect
to the community building yeah i give
the community building significant
weight because it can address
um or it's got the potential to address
the um
uh some of the the points raised by
third parties in terms of um you know
clinic admissions
and then within that as well i tie in
the the
parking facility that's
adjacent to and as part of the community
um building as well
councillor shaw just aggregated those
two but you effectively deal with them
all all as part and parcel of the same
facility i do correct and in any case
there's agreement between myself and
council assure that significant weight
should be given to that facility
and
in respect
of
public open space recreation space
pedestrian cycling links through the
site
mr gascoigne has um different weightings
for these in 12.18 and 12.28 to 30 but
your position please in respect to the
weight to be attributed to those yeah a
significant way because so whilst the
public open space and links through the
site recreation land
are required to serve
the appeal site and then also be a
benefit for the wider community
to you
which we'll see tomorrow is
coming to a site that isn't publicly
accessible um and it's opening up that
site to be able to to be used by
people wanting to
come and
enjoy the public open space and the um
and the areas of play
highway improvements and highway safety
um councillor shaw accepted significant
weight in respect to highway safety
your position please as to the weight
that should be attributed to highway
improvements and highway safety yeah i
agree with counselors sure that it's
it's significant
the reasons
that she was taken through last week
position in respect of uh drainage
please what's proposed and what weight
you attribute to that yeah so the um
i think it's probably best set out in
the committee report given that the the
flood risk assessment is quite extensive
but essentially
um the the flood and drainage strategy
um is looking to ensure that
surface water is dealt with on the
appeal sites and won't make it worse
anywhere else
but in addition it actually goes on in
the committee report and i think the
local lead flood authority expressed
that actually there would be a benefit
to some of those residents to the south
of the site who currently experience
um some surface water flooding that that
wouldn't do once the um once the schemes
built up
so moderate weight
thank you
economic benefits um
and uh councillor shaw said lower than
moderate in respective economic benefits
your position please in terms of
economic benefits yeah i think it's the
only one that we disagree
on so i adopt the position of my
colleague that moderate weight
should be afforded to economic benefits
which is to do with the
generation of jobs
um throughout the build programme
including apprenticeships
which my client
it uses up and down the country
and also the
net spend that could anticipated to be
generated that would
effectively be spent throughout rockford
and the low quality
i think we've picked them all up mr
pycroft in terms of benefits let's just
um finally conclude with the tilt with
with the um the balance that's required
pursuant to section 38.6
uh applications determined in accordance
with the development plan
unless material considerations indicate
otherwise
and then obviously we have the tilted
balance that's agreed to apply in terms
of material considerations so planning
permission should be granted
unless the
any adverse impacts significantly and
demonstrably outweigh the benefits of
the scheme when considered as a whole
your position please
in respect of whether planning
permission should be granted applying
those tests yeah i agree with councillor
shaw's evidence last week that planning
permission should be granted when the
tilted balance is is
is correctly applied and just pausing
there
final point for you in planning terms we
have a position where the application
was twice recommended for approval
by the council's professional officers
and where following cross-examination
council assure
giving evidence for the local planning
authority
agreed that even taking the council's
case in respect of highways impacts at
its highest so adopting that
her view taking everything into account
was that planning permission
should be granted
what weight do you give
to
the views of the professional officer
and the chair of the council's planning
committee giving evidence on behalf of
the local planning authority in respect
of the point that they all agree that
planning permission should be granted i
give significant weight
thank you sir
thank you
okay thank you
so um obviously we'll have a luncheon
adjournment now and then i'll turn
firstly to uh mr parkinson to see if
he's got any cross-examination for you
mr pycroft and then see what the
rule six party have
we're coming up to ten past one
um if we were to take 40 minutes that
would get us back to ten to two wouldn't
it is that okay with everyone yeah okay
let's do that then so i'll adjourn now
we'll resume
at 1.50 thank you
oh
the inquiry is resumed ladies and
gentlemen
just before
we
continue with the business can i just
mention for the
conditions session later i would hope
that
an updated version can be printed out so
i have a hard copy in front of me is
that going to be possible please
yes
good thank you because i
one of my comments was i wanted to see
the reasons for the proposed imposition
of each of the conditions and that
hadn't been
on the schedule as i'd seen it to date
so it'd be helpful to have that so i
thought if i mentioned it now if copying
needs to be done or printing then it can
happen while we're
having this session hopefully
i don't know whether i i've not got a
printed version of that so if if it has
to be a composite then if i can have it
at least both of those in in
in hard copy form that will be fine
thank you thank you
okay so putting that to one side um mr
parkinson have you got questions for
mr pycroft uh no sir
i'll just leave this alone um
no we we've uh reviewed very carefully
over lunch what mr pikov said and as i
anticipated that the points that need to
be covered have already been covered
with mr blair so i don't
okay that's helpful thank you
bear with me
thank you so mr foster then for the rule
six party have you got questions for
mr pycroft on either his or mr
gascoigne's evidence yes i do sir um
i wonder if i could um make a couple of
points first before i get into questions
one is we were i've been passed
something
by chap called mr mick vanner
who spoke last week mr vanessa spoke yes
i mean just just let me be clear that
what you're going to be doing now
because this this part of the
proceedings these questions to
mr pycroft
on his evidence not additional
matters introduced so so what is it what
is it you want to tell me it's asking
you sir whether you're prepared to
accept this from mr vanner he's asked us
if we could put it forward well i i
don't know what it is and i think i'm
unlikely to accept it because it's
whatever it is it's coming extremely
late in the proceedings mr van has
already spoken
i've got the evidence that he's put
forward
i'm afraid that uh i i i can't have drip
feeding of information like this it's
not i agree so it's not mine
this isn't directed at you but it's
directed through you i'm afraid okay um
it's the first i'm very much the
messenger in that particular issue yeah
understood
right
um
may i make a point of clarification that
is relevant to the subsequent
questioning okay
um when i spoke before about cumulative
impact and whether ser 2 and scr8 had
been included in the ringway jacobs
i've re-examined that documentation and
confirmed that ser 8 wasn't in that
table of numbers
if you wish i can bring that to the
table and show the participants well if
if you've prepared uh
it in written form if it could be copied
and handed in to myself and the
appellants and the council then that
that
is something i can
have regard to but i think that'll be
the easiest way to do that i i can if it
helps uh refer to the pages in the
document
pages 19 and 21
where it spells there's a table that
spells out the numbers
and then on page 20 that's page 19 on
page 21
is a paragraph that spells out the ser
numbers that relate to the three numbers
in the column in the area 2015 to 2025.
well as i say if if if what you're
telling me that from is from a sheet
that could be copied and handed in that
might be easier than just my my simple
note so if that's that's possible as
long as long as
mr parkinson and miss read also have
copies of that then it can be
considered and responded to as
appropriate
um so i'm first going to
put forward two or three questions in
relation to the mr gascoigne part of the
thing
i think we did touch upon them
last week
and um
i'm not sure they got clearly addressed
so if if i forgive me if i'm repeating
uh and if they were clearly addressed
then i'll withdraw
so
the first question i have is
do you have evidence of mode shift
from car to public transport resulting
from development
for an area with similar socio-economic
and geographical characteristics as
rockford district
i'm so sorry to interject at the first
question sir but points like that are
highways points that should have been
put to mr blair and we had an extensive
discussion
i did put them last week it was put to
mr blair
and
um
well it was put to mr blair and i i have
to check my notes but um you you got an
answer from mr blair i i believe it i i
recall it being deferred to mr
gascoigne's representative speaking
but
if that's not the case then i will
obviously withdraw that
and obviously the answer that we got was
not very significant
facilities
um i raised the question
mr gascoigne describes a wide variety of
facilities within walking distance as
benefits of the location
and um
again it was deferred and um
so in i'll pick out two or three of
those in terms of the hospital
um
what is the benefit
uh good afternoon can you can you hear
me okay and yes are you okay with me
sort of
facing away from you as it were just the
layout of the room i think with the
layout of the room with spider if you'll
have to as long as long as you know you
you will obviously acknowledge mr foster
when you uh answer some of the points
but you'll have to turn away to to get
your documentation yeah
um yeah in in answer to your question uh
mr foster the um mr gascoigne's proof of
evidence sets out a
list of um services and facilities
amenities
that are within walking distance of the
site one of them is
um the hospital that i think you took mr
blair to last week but it's it's a sort
of less to say the range of um
facilities are
are within walking distance
uh and that's agreed with the council of
course because it's in the planning
statement of common ground
i i understand what the purpose was
my question is
what is the benefit of that hospital
yeah well the the benefit isn't
specifically the hospital it's this the
the range of services and facilities
that within walking distance so you
recall last week with councillor shaw
and in my own chief now that we were
talking about um new residential
development being located in located in
sustainable locations okay and and
really it's a sort of list it wouldn't
say all housing needs to be next to this
hospital it's just a a location that
that is within walking let me rephrase
the question then do you know what kind
of hospital that is
well i heard the exchange with you and
mr blair um
last friday it was
and it's a care
a care facility
i'm sorry rather than
you know a hospital within an accident
an emergency it's a mental health
facility yeah and a care home daily care
home for the elderly
i'm just trying to put the context in
how that's been described as a benefit
of this new development well proposing
well it's not it's not i'll move on to
the next one thank you no no i'd hear
the answer please
sorry all i was going to say it's not
something that we're providing it's not
a benefit of our our site the benefit of
our site is the location that it's in
and as i said
therefore the ability of for people to
access
services immunities things like
perhaps visiting relatives or working at
this hospital within walking distance
i understand that
okay i'm just trying to put into context
what this
when one describes a hospital one
normally imagines something like south
in general hospital not a mental health
care home
right um similar discussion you talk
about being in walking distance of the
doctor's surgery
current doctor surgery is over
subscribed due to shortage of doctors so
being able to walk to somewhere that
can't cope with the current level of
of um
population requirement how how would you
describe that as a as a benefit
uh well it's it again it's the the
benefit of the site is that it's in a
sustainable location and you could
connect
walk to
these locations so sorry okay um
but
but the point here is of course we
recognize that and we're providing the
land as part of the application for uh
for a care facility in its own right and
the financial contribution to existing
places so if that were to put towards an
extension to this clinic then for
example it you know people would be able
to okay to walk and access the
facilities there
i would agree it's a wonderful
aspiration but the reality is of that
hospital that walking distance
surgery has got empty rooms because they
can't get doctors so you're talking
about hypothetical thing for the future
there is a doctor shortage around here
and there's no sign of it being resolved
um
sorry
i was there a question at the end of
that cause i couldn't come back on
no no just reflecting on your answer
okay
um
holt farm schools are you aware that the
head teachers oppose the development
uh well i i've seen the the
correspondence from them um
it appears to be
related to highway safety
um and perhaps a perception of what
those highway safety
uh considerations are and of course as
the inquiry's gone on we've now got an
agreed position with the with the local
planning authority on that i don't think
that we've then had
um the reaction from the from the
schools okay thank you
um cycling again it's one that i touched
upon last week briefly but i don't think
it was
satisfactorily answered so i'll just
re-ask if i may
mr gascoigne described the site as
having potential
by cycling to reduce car trips of up to
10 kilometers
is that correct
i understand that to be the case if i
could just turn up the
part of the proof
i think it relates back to um
some of the ill roots in the trouble
sorry mr pike so doing interrupt why are
you looking that way because you're
going back to the proof just give me the
reference that you're going to well i
haven't found it yet sir but it's mr
gascoigne's proof
um and then i
and then i can see up page 33
and paragraphs 8.7 and 8.8
and there's a quote to one of the core
documents cd 6.11
and it says cycling has the potential to
replace trips made by other modes
typically up to 10 kilometers which i
think is mr foster's question to me
my question was outside of the
actual appellant site and the very
nearby rockford cycle network
uh
what are the opportunities for people
through cycle networks to use
to get to the places that mr gascoigne
offered as examples
well i think some of this is perhaps
being covered by my colleague in in his
evidence and the travel plan that's um
appended to it but the point is that
it's connecting to the to the wider
network
um
you know rather than saying specifically
on cycle lane
number x or y
okay but would you agree the wider
network doesn't provide cycling
facilities once you get outside of
rochford i'm so sorry i'm just going to
stop here again i am afraid that if
we're talking about cycle facilities etc
etc those are points that firstly were
covered with mr blair and secondly
relate to his evidence yeah you you did
you did put those points to mr blair and
you did get responses there so
really uh it's only
if you're asking questions that haven't
already been put to one of the witnesses
or if that witness was unable to answer
then that's certainly legitimate to try
the next of the opponents witnesses but
i guess i'm reflecting the point that
they weren't very satisfactorily
answered but i'll move on
again one that was touched upon last
week mr gascoigne talked about the area
being well serviced by public transport
network
could you briefly explain
the bus routes that run along ashley and
road i think this is again is it it's uh
a transport point that you put to mr
blair again i'm sorry i'm reflecting
that it wasn't very well answered
perhaps i should ask miss reed to ask my
questions for me it would probably save
some time
i think the point is um
mr foster that
you you got the answers that were given
and clearly if they they weren't the
answers you you wanted or were expecting
then
i i understand your position now but i
mean the the witness gave you
the answers in his area of expertise
that he felt were appropriate to the
questions put yes sir i i guess i should
have gone back on those questions or
those answers at that point but i was
very aware that people were keen to get
away and avoid the traffic
so i'll move on new questions
um are you aware of the new highway code
rules and guidelines regarding
pedestrians and cyclists no i'm so sorry
i'm i'm i i know it's difficult for mr
foster and i'm really genuinely i'm not
trying to no
no no no no sorry that the the
difficulty sir is that mr pie croft and
mr foster mr pycroft is dealing with the
planning evidence
and mr pla mr blair was dealing with the
highways
issues
so
in terms of different areas of expertise
these points are points that
either were made to mr blair or that
should have been because they were
within his area of expertise
and i don't want my planning expert who
has got a different area of expertise to
be asked questions that should have
properly been put to mr blair
but
that is a fair comment and i i i would
endorse that because the point is the
quest the questions that you can
legitimately put to
mr pycroft are those that
relate to subject matter of his proof of
evidence
and mr gascoigne's proof of evidence as
mr pycroft has adopted that
so the the the information
in
mr gascoigne's evidence that
in some ways touches on what you're
talking about i think mr foster is uh
relates to the
um
the accessibility of the site
that's that's the point that
you picked up on a moment ago when you
talked about hospital and cycling and
that
but but they're not highway matters as
they're not highway
they're not specific highway matters i
suppose what i'm trying to say whereas
when you start raising something
relating to changes to the highway code
that clearly doesn't fall under any of
the areas of expertise of either mr
gascoigne or mr pycroft so it's not a
legitimate question to this witness
okay sir i would probably
just make the point
that
had these things been generally
publicized when we were submitting
evidence we would have done that but we
didn't so i understand your point sir
um can i move on to things that mr
pycroft did talk about please
the core strategy
identified the need
for highway capacity on all of the
significant developments in the local
plan is that correct
the core strategy identifies um that
improvements are needed in various
locations throughout the districts in
terms of highways
and my question was
in all of the major developments in the
in the core strategy
and the different um
ser type numbers identified the need for
highway capacity improvement do you
agree with that well um
i don't
agree with that because what what we're
looking up for this site you recall
council shaw was taken to this and she
was in agreement with us
is the appendix h1 to policy h3 and it's
those specific
requirements for this site that's that's
been sought to met which if i can find
it i will
reference when you find it sure
an appendix in slap bang in the middle
of the document but it's page
56
of the core strategy
and in relation to this site it says
local highway capacity and
infrastructure improvements including
contribution to traffic management of
washington road
and then
five other bullet points
six other bullet points rather below it
sorry could you repeat the first
paragraph there
so the first bullet point says local
highway the first paragraph you read out
please
i think that was oh that was it i think
appendix h1 for page 56. one that
referred to local highway capacity the
statement you just made yeah it says
local highway capacity and
infrastructure improvements inc
including contributions to traffic
management of washington road
yeah
sorry and
it's now in full agreement with this
council that we've met that bullet point
that's not my question
that policy said improvements to highway
capacity and infrastructure is that
correct
that's what it says yeah correct thank
you
does it say that ser a is exempt from
that policy for highway capacity
improvement
no it's asking the whoever's
sorry
i i i've given everyone the courtesy of
providing an answer and qualifying it if
they so wish so
mr foster i do need to be able to make a
note of what mr poycroft is is saying
okay
thank you it does say that and and what
i was going to say is there's an
expectation that all of these bullet
points will be met when the site comes
forward and there's agreement with the
authority that that we're doing
that
so you're saying there wasn't an except
sera on the highway capacity improvement
issue
you you asked me was there an exception
for this
site
sorry ladies
sorry sir
so i you you asked me was there an
exception for this site not to meet that
bullet point and i was saying no
it's expected that all of these bullet
points will be met when the site comes
forward
all right thank you
um
could you point me to any evidence
that the
um
either the local planning authority or
the highways authority
tested the cumulative impact of ser 2
and ser 8
against the definition of severe
well
obviously we've got this statement of
common ground with
the highways authority that confirms
that it's not severe
and they would be
and we've got the
um statement of common ground with the
local planning authority saying that
it's not severe or their
technical highways witness
and sorry i was just going to say and
both would be aware that ser 2 was
online as it would have been being
delivered
that wasn't my question my question was
have you got any evidence that
either the local planning authority
or the highways authority
tested
scr2 and scr8 cumulatively against
severe impact
well i would say yes we have got the
evidence and that's the statements of
common ground
could you point where in that it says
it's tested the
impact
cumulatively against severe
well well it doesn't say that in the
statements of common ground but my point
is both the highways authority
and mr flexman on behalf of this
authority would have been well aware as
to where ser 2
was up to in terms of its assessment of
of this site coming forward as well
could i point you to
the right honourable mp mark francoise
evidence on tuesday last week
where he met with the
essex highway authority who explained in
a meeting that they didn't have a
definition of severe could you confirm
can you demonstrate where essex has a
definition of severe right i'm going to
i'm afraid interject again sir we're
going back again in respect of matters
to do with the highways authority
and the definition
of a severe residual cumulative impact
and again those when this goes to mr
blair's evidence
in respect of highways consultation
responses yeah
i
i'm trying to be as flexible as i can mr
foster but you you you can't simply try
and put the same
questions or
questions that are more appropriate to
to one witness
you can't just try and put them
a second time round
to the planning witness
um
right i recognize that sale as a fair
point problem is we're trying to draw
out answers that weren't given before
but i'll have to move on obviously
mr pycroft you talked about flood risks
in my evidence last week i demonstrated
examples in my evidence of flood risk
and i was not cross-examined on that so
do you believe my evidence was wrong
well
i don't know it's the answer to that
okay um but what i do know is that
obviously
the uh
flood risk the risk of flood on the
appeal site
and locality or as a result of the site
coming forward in the locality
has been fully assessed by the um
county's um
local lead fl as a local lead flood
authority
and have got no objection and in fact
considers that there's a a benefit you
heard me say that in chief
that's in the committee report
thank you
um
i'm going to move on to
the
appeal that was rejected in kent
by the housing inspector
um despite there being a housing land
shortfall which which appeal are we
talking about and it was um where am i
going to find it it was um appeal
reference mc 19 15 1566 you know i mean
in in terms of the evidence before me
where where is it please just so i can
have it in front of me is it part of
your documentation or if i can if i
could assist um so i think they in
fairness the rule six party appended the
um or made reference to it in their
additional letter and then the mp sent
in
the inspect sorry the secretary of
state's decision letter and then we
followed that up with the full report i
don't know whether it's been printed i
suspect you don't have it with you none
of that's found its way okay yeah that
was last week yeah
yeah as i say
i think we pre-printed this um but
haven't actually handed it up to you yet
yeah um i'm told i i couldn't recall
whether i'd seen it i thought i hadn't
is it to hand now or not it's in the
other room we can run and get it
okay can we
if you put your question
to mr pycroft but if it can be
obtained whilst you're doing that then i
can
catch up so so if you give me reference
uh paragraph reference numbers as you're
asking your points of mr pycroff please
i don't have the paragraph reference so
i'd have to refer to that
document from
the mp
okay
so my question is are you aware of that
um
rejection
i'm aware of the yeah the appeal
decision yeah yeah are you
sorry sorry sorry mr foster you're just
so so i'm my notes are going to be
comprehensive when i revisit them or
rather understandable when i revisit
them later
is this the
um appeal decision that um mr pycroft
was taken through in his evidence in
chief it is yes so the notes that i made
at that time relate to that one okay as
long as i've got that
clear in my head so okay sorry to have
interrupted you if you'd like to start
that again
um
are you aware of the inspector's main
reasoning for rejection
uh yes
there well there was several reasons um
rather than just there just been one
main reason um
that we that is ex
explained in the inspectors reports
that the highway's impact was severe so
highways impacts and the finding of the
severe impacts was one of those reasons
but but as you'll appreciate when you've
if given that you've read the the report
the inspector actually says
even if the highways
were acceptable the appeal would be
dismissed because of the loss of the
it was a big orchard so it's the loss of
the best and most versatile agricultural
land and the landscape harm so my
reading of it is
you know forget about the highways if
this site was going to be refused on
those on the loss of bmv and the
landscape alone but
your reading of it but but in fairness
uh when you asked me are we you were
aware of the main issue if i had to say
a main issue it would be the combination
of the bmv
and the landscape
albeit there are other reasons as to why
the appeal was um dismissed okay thank
you
um
one of the
much has been
mentioned about
housing shortage housing planning
shortage allocations and so on um are
you aware of what the inspector said in
that kent appeal in relation to
the housing shortfall
i understand that there was a short
shortfall sorry i'm just thinking do i
know medway no
um but i don't know the context as to
whether it was the same or similar to
where we are now i know that they didn't
have a five-year housing land supply
that's correct but i don't know in terms
of
whether um well we know that it wasn't
an allocated site there and here we're
talking about an allocated you know the
last of the allocated sites to come
forward to uh to to meet the requirement
perhaps i can just help to clarify that
before moving on to my next next uh just
just before you start to clarify i i
sense that mr parkinson's got something
to hand up to me so i have um
unfortunately we've only got one copy
but if that's okay i'll hand this to
them
so this is the um inspector's report and
the secretary of state's decision yeah
it's the whole thing
thank you if you've only got the one
copy and others wanted do you want me to
give it you back so that you can it can
be copied i mean basically i i want to
have
a copy of it
okay yeah okay
put that to one side then for now if
you're moving on past it thank you
so apologies again mr foster for
stopping you mid mid flow but
um yeah the um
one of the things inspector said is that
the um the appellant had argued the case
about
shortage of land supply
okay
and the inspector said
that each scheme needs to be considered
on its own merits
without knowing in detail what any other
impacts might be elsewhere
i.e
the shortage of land supply would cause
pressure somewhere else in the district
so he said this is not a consideration
that takes the appellant's case any
further so would you agree that the same
logic should apply here
no um because the reasons i was given in
my chief
are that that where we are here is that
there is a shortfall in the housing
because this allocated site ieser aids
hasn't come forward whereas in medway
um the issue was that okay there was a
shortfall in the five-year housing land
supply but that site was um and you know
unallocated in the in the development
plan it wasn't a development plan like
we have here that's wholly reliant on
the site coming forward
if there wasn't a shortfall elsewhere
would that then mean that the logic that
applied in kent should apply here
i'd yeah i don't think that that's
correct so i'm afraid because
do you mean a shortfall
a shortfall where in
if there's a shortfall in kent it's
clearly not material to us here if there
isn't a shortfall here i'm going to
challenge some of the arguments if there
isn't a shortfall here would you would
you agree
the
logic that was used by the inspector in
kent would be equally sound here no
because the short for i think we're
talking at cross purposes there's a
shortfall in the five-year housing land
supply in kent
in raynham and
in rochford
that's one consideration
but also here there's a shortfall in the
planned period supply because the
allocated sites i.e our allocated site
hasn't come forward
okay
can i come on to talk about that or ask
questions about that please yeah
um
first of all do you agree that the
housing need figure was an imposed
figure not one calculated by the local
planning authority
i are you accused by the east of england
plan
i agree that the figure came from the
regional assembly i think imposed um
uh well i suppose yeah yeah i agree that
the the east of england regional
assembly set the housing requirement for
rochford and as you'll have heard in my
chief actually is significantly lower
than what the government would set the
figure as okay thank you
um
in your proof of evidence and the
discussions are you described
a housing shortfall
how many is that shortfall versus the
adopted housing requirement what's the
housing trajectory
shortfall through to 2025. so you've
seen the
housing
supply and delivery statement of common
ground
yeah so it's agreed is the in answer to
your question the shortfall
to 2025 is 331 dwellings which is
paragraph 2.6 of that statement of
common ground just for the inspector's
record okay
2.6 yeah and it's and the yeah 2.6 is
the paragraph and 331 is the agreed
shortfall with the with the authority
okay
thank you three three one
um
are you
aware that in november 2021 an appeal
was won by a developer
to build a retirement village of 222
homes in cherry orchard way rochford
well i am because you mentioned it
earlier on in the inquiry
but if i can just comment on that so
that that site isn't in the council's
trajectory
um but i had a look at the appeal
decision and obviously it's an outline
consent
and you'll be aware from my proof as in
the one with with my name on it that
there's um
specific criteria for sites with
outlying consent to be considered
deliverable
and if it were to be included in the
trajectory you need clear evidence that
that site was going to come forward i.e
um confirmation of a reserve you know a
reserve matters application coming in a
developer wanting to to approve it and
sorry just another point on that so so
um so the inspector's clear you you said
222 units
i think
homes yeah half of the
half of the um permission is c2
so
um i don't know if you're aware but the
you don't treat a c2
unit
as the same as a
as a home
and you apply a ratio to it it's not as
simple as saying 222 homes are coming
forward on that side
you actually divide it by 1.8 okay
we'll move on i think we can still
address that issue
i don't know whether i'm allowed to say
this but i talked to the developer who's
bringing reserve matters application
forward in june and expects the comp the
development to be completed in
2324.
so
in statement of the common ground it
identified a further 222
dwellings by uh coincidence in the land
north of london road west of raleigh
approved subject to 106.
you you're nodding in agreement yes yeah
well i can talk about that if you'd like
um i'll check first are you aware that
this section 106 agreement was approved
last week
i am yeah again you mentioned it last
week but but that those units don't
address the shortfall in the planned
period well we'll come we'll come on to
the my version of the maths in a moment
okay
um are you also aware that blair blah
owned that land with the 222. they're
one of the two developers on there yeah
correct 222 extra bit is blur as i
understand it
i thought actually it was in
countrysides but and the two developers
were working together on on the uh on
the site but i'm not ensuring you know
i bought
okay
so
um
would it be reasonable to assume that if
the blur application for scr8 is
rejected they'll have capacity to build
the 222 extra homes
no it does it doesn't work like that and
also it's in a separate part of the
the borough but the the the points that
you're right that you raised before
about well actually this plan period
shortfall will be addressed by the
cherry
care home
and they
um sorry
the appeal decision that you just take
me to and the london roadside is is not
right because obviously that london
roadside is already under construction
it's already in the trajectory up to
2025 and those additional units will
follow after that
so again um the inspector's record the
trajectory is cd 8.04
and you you you're seeing that mr foster
that that you know those 500 odd units
that are currently under construction
take us up to 2025 and anything
additional will come forward beyond the
plan period
could i could talk to table seven on the
statement of common ground
under ser one where it describes the
application for further 222
subject to s106 that 222 isn't included
in the number in the column that is
added up that's absolutely correct but
what i'm saying
[Music]
so
they're not in the trajectory the 550
are but not the 222. absolutely
absolutely the 222 were not in the
trajectory but nor would they be
expected to come forward by 2025
because the 550 when you look at the
actual trajectory the big spreadsheet i
agreed with the council cd 8.04
you'll see that there's four years of
full completions on that site
you one doesn't just add in the 222 it's
an extension of the site that would go
on beyond the plan period
and perhaps i've been over simplistic
has not been a
builder but if bloor don't get approval
for scra does that not free up their
resource to rather more quickly develop
the 222 no no they might blow law homes
build 4000 homes a year
nationally
so one of those sites
is the london roadside
and they're hoping that one of the sites
to make up that would also be the
washington road it's not a a straight
swap
but they would be expecting to get the
resources to develop the asean
washington roadside what i'm suggesting
is if they that could get them for that
and it's not approved surely they could
get them for the 222.
london no and it doesn't work like that
for the reasons why i gave them the in
the trajec on the trajectory
okay i must say i find the maths
difficult to understand on that simple
matter
the other thing
the
also the
figures
in the trajectory don't include windfall
numbers is that correct
well they they include windfall sites as
in sight so so
you you're aware the windfall sites the
sites that aren't allocated in the in
the plan yes okay so so within the
current trajectory there are windfall
sites i.e sites that are being developed
or have got planning permission that are
not allocated in the plan but there's
not an additional windfall allowance
because there's a specific test that
authorities need to to meet to include a
windfall allowance and this authority
can't demonstrate
that evidence would you accept that
the authority doesn't know every
windfall site that's going to come along
in the next few years
well every authority is the same i i do
yeah i do accept that an authority
doesn't know by the nature windfall
sites but what the test is is for
compelling evidence of past trends to
demonstrate that they that they're
likely to come forward and in this
authority
there isn't i mean you've seen the
completion figures
that have been achieved
it's perhaps when you look at those it's
perhaps no surprise that there isn't the
compelling evidence that windfall sites
have
come forward
at a rate to to justify and allow a
further allowance how many do you think
have come forward each year on average
for the last five years
on windfall allowance i i don't know the
i could probably find that out
and i can tell you it's 49
and interestingly on the um since
our first evidence was submitted the
planning committees approved 39
in central rochford that weren't on any
plan anywhere okay yeah my
point i'm getting to is we've got 222
which you say
for retirement village is less than 222
but some of them are care home places
mostly not
222 for north of london road
and
49 per annum
windfall sites
okay no because if i can just answer
your point on the windfall sites i think
we're soaking up cross purposes so there
are already windfall sites you're saying
that the average completion rate on
windfall sites in this authority is 49.
okay
now in the trajectory there are already
a chunk of windfall science that are
expected to come forward so they will
replicate your fortune and they're all
i.e they're already included in the
supply they're already included in the
trajectory we're not talking about an
additional 49 coming forward and meeting
this shortfall the evidence just simply
does not exist here how many are
included in the coming five years well
the five-year supply is 1500 units
i'm asking how many windfalls
but i think i think if you if you give
mr pycroft chance i think he's he's
finding that information for you i was
just starting to make a note of that
yeah
i mean for an exact figure we'd have to
look at the trajectory and and be able
to set that out so but we know that the
five-year figure is 1537.
and then in the trajectory
there are already what cd is that please
sorry that's 8.04
you would have to remove the allocations
which is
london road
the few that are left on scr 2
et cetera
my point is
that there would i would imagine you'd
only need to find 250 to meet your 49
per year
and there will be more than 250 windfall
sites already in this in the trajectory
do you want me to have another game what
you're saying
okay from my own experience of
relatively new experience in terms of
planning but windfall sites come up that
are not in the plan not in the
trajectory they do and there's no
dispute that they
have come up and are in the trajectory
any dispute would be if there was if
you're inviting the inspector to make an
additional windfall allowance i'm
suggesting that the evidence just isn't
there to
to
to satisfy that and in fact that was a
point that we agreed with the
the council
in removing their windfall allowance
from the five-year supply
um okay we're we're not going to come to
an agreement are we well i've left my
calculator in my bag anyway we've got um
my suggestion is that we've
you've made a clear statement that 331
is a shortfall in a trajectory
i suggested that there are
various mitigations that say that that
shortfall would be covered and i just
add one more point if i will
sir
um following the leader of the council's
statement about rochford having
over-delivered in the last three years i
took the trouble last night to check
and the
planning policy communities gov dot uk
website shows the housing delivery test
for 2021
it says rochford through the period from
2018 2021
achieved 103
versus the
proposed delivery
and the consequence is
none
whereas if anybody's short
it requires them to take an action plan
so the leaders statement about over
delivery
is evidenced by the government's own
website
i don't know if there's a question from
mr pycroft there so i don't know if
there's a question so i was waiting to
see if there was a question to mr
pinecroft there's is nothing that you're
putting to mr pinecroft to respond to
okay i'll ask a question
mr pinecross would you agree
that the
uh
local government be sorry the
housing
housing
goodness me sorry
the housing
department the planning policy and
communities department of the government
dot uk is a reliable source for gaining
information about district council's
achievement of building
yes in safari it measures the housing
delivery test on an annual basis per
authority
okay
you would agree that is a good source
well yes insofar as it measures housing
delivery tests against the mechanisms in
it but but you'll be aware and the
leader will be aware
and hopefully the inspector's aware that
that the housing delivery test only
looks at the last three years
on a specific measurement to work out
whether for example you the the buffer
should be increased from 5 to 20
but but what we've got in the statement
of common ground is an agreed position
that that across the plan period so from
since 2006
there's a huge shortfall of 829 units
and the planned period
um requirement isn't going to be met and
hence the 331 shortfall it's it's a
slightly different
uh well it's a very different way of
sort of measuring the uh
the delivery housing delivery test is
one measure against the development plan
and and the council's performance
of meeting this requirement is another
okay that's the government's measure yes
the government produces the housing
delivery test but there's also an
expectation on this authority
to produce
to deliver the housing that it set out
in its housing in its core strategy
okay
you've talked about
housing
five-year land supply short fall
are you aware that the
development of the new local plan is
paused
i'm not aware that the development as a
local plan is paused
um but what i would say is
that flies in the face of everything
that government is expecting of this
authority to do
ie
keep a plan produce a plan every five
years keep it up to date
then produce a new one
i'd be very surprised if if that was the
authority's position
um and in terms of
in relation to five-year housing land
supply clearly the the
authority is going to
hamper its ability to meet a five-year
housing land supply if it doesn't get a
new plan in place okay
we're not suggesting for one moment
there won't be a new plan we're saying
it's paused
the reason it's paused and i showed in
evidence is a letter from the leader of
the council
and the planning portfolio holder and
the leader of the playing policy
committee challenging the numbers
well it did i'm so sorry sir this is
brand new evidence now
no it isn't it was in the submission of
evidence on the 23rd of december
but just take take me to which
attachment it was i i do recall seeing a
letter
along the lines of what you just
referred to um mr foster so
no attachment one was your uh jacob's
report i think but oh no sorry sir it's
the attachment one to the additional
letter
from the rule 6
yes
bear with me while i
turn that one up
[Music]
um
so i think it's the letter dated first
of november 2021
correct there's attachment one on the
23rd of december submission
again i've not got it yet bear with me
i'm not sure
i think it was one that i asked to be
handed in as another copy because i
hadn't got a copy of that
with me so i still
haven't got that although i am conscious
of the fact that i've seen it i think
that
mystery do you have it no but if mr
pycroft's got a copy i'm happy for him
to be asked because he's the one that
needs to see it okay and if i need to
look at it later then yeah i say i know
i've seen it i can't put my hand on it
now but as long as you take the question
slowly so i've got the right notes mr
foster and mr pycroft will give you the
his response to it okay
so
my question was um what first of all are
you aware the local plan is paused not
stopped it's poor slightly pending these
clarifications the letter was
to the um
department to
write honorable mike gove
was challenging that
numbers were being imposed and the
letter from the housing
minister
honourable christopher pincher mp came
back stating
whilst the nppf does
define a method for calculating local
needs gives a starting point for local
authorities
it emphasizes a local housing need does
not set a target for the number of homes
to be built now the local plan process
which
was started about two years ago and is
slowly going forward
includes about 200 sites that have been
offered by various landowners
and they were i think the spatial
options document was mentioned but um
by mr pycroft but would you agree
that that spatial options was only a
consultation paper at this stage and it
wasn't recommending anything particular
well two uh two points so firstly you
asked whether i knew
that the plan was on hold that there's
nothing in the letter from the leader to
say that he's putting the plan on hold
he might be contesting
the
method for calculating local housing
need but he doesn't say that he's
putting his plan on hold and in fact the
response from mr pinscher i'm sorry i
didn't say on hold i said paused paul
okay well paused
um
and in fact the letter in response from
mr pincher mp
is an invitation for this authority to
get on with its new plan
so so and through that set a housing
requirement slightly different from
local housing need but set a housing
requirement that it thinks
it could do and then in answer to your
second question i'm sorry i forgot i
forgot what it was
what i'm trying to get to is how given
the situation the in terms of the local
plan
the comments made in the spatial options
spatial consultation consultation
and the fact that we've got 200 or
approximately 200 sites put forward
how can you be describing the shortfall
in future
land allocation sorry yeah forgive me
it's come back to me you asked me
whether the
spatial options paper was a consultation
document yes it is a consultation
document
um we don't know what the final figure
is going to be for rochford but what we
do know
is that the government standard method
comes up with a figure over the new plan
period of 7200 units
and the supply including the appeal site
only identifies 4 200.
i asked my question again
we've got a local plan in development
paused as i said for the reasons i
explained
we've got 200 approximately 200 sites
offered
and going through the consideration
through the spatial options and the
officers working on the
analysis of them how can you how can you
claim when we're at that point in the
plan
that there's a shortfall
well
well i can claim it because the
council's own document
says that there's a shortfall so so
you're aware of the spatial options plan
and this council it's it's planning
policy committee and their members
agreed that they that that plan should
go out to consultation and then their
full council agreed and we heard from
council ashore last week that they
should go out to consultation and you
heard what i said in chief and what
council assure agreed on last week that
every single one of those options
identifies a minimum of four thousand
two hundred but the but the plan
recognizes that that isn't enough
so those 200 sites that people have put
forward might come in an options two
three and four
but
every single option relies on existing
allocations such as this site coming
forward and that's the council's
position
i i am aware of that i'm a member of the
planning policy committee i'm very aware
of that spatial options plan being put
out into consultation
but does it not remain the case
that we have not yet
gotten to the point of identifying the
allocations just bought whatever the
need might be
well correct you don't sorry that
doesn't mean we have it we won't get the
number
correct you don't know what your housing
requirement is but you know that the
government policy is that every
authority must meet its local housing
need you know what that local housing
need is and as a member of the planning
policy committee you would have
accepted that existing allocations would
come forward to it to meet the 4200 in
every option
can you explain please
for a plan that is in development
with hundreds 200
sites put forward
you can you can definitively say there's
a shortfall
well i can't because you you
your evidence
no no no no we're talking about cross
purposes the spatial options paper
might say that 200 sites have been put
forward if every one of those 200 sites
is allocated and then the authority
approves planning permission on those
allocated sites
then clearly they will come forward and
there wouldn't be a shortfall my
evidence says that there's a shortfall
based on the council's trajectory and
then as we've discussed in chief the
spatial options paper itself identifies
that there's a shortfall and greenbelt
land will be needed to address the local
housing need not not
in addition to those 200 sites those 200
sites would assist
in meeting those options but would rely
on on greenbelt release
they haven't been analyzed yet and
haven't been allocated how can you say
there would be a shortfall is that not a
presumption on your part no no it's not
because we know what the government
standard method is for calculating local
housing need
7 200 units and we know what the
the the existing supply is 4 200 units
including the appeals site
so it's not a presumption to say that
there's a shortfall against that 200
some of those 200 sites will be need i
agree will be needed to meet that that
shortfall and hopefully once they've
been allocated and come forward then
then there wouldn't be a shortfall but
that would involve green belt release
letter from
the right honourable christopher pincher
said it's up to the local authority to
identify the need in terms of the
numbers
and that's not been done yet so how can
you
presume there will be a short form no
the
the
there is a shortfall because the
starting position of any plan is that it
meets its local housing need and that
figure is set by government what what mr
pincher is talking about is you take
that figure and then you need to come up
with your housing requirement to work
out whether it's going to be higher or
lower
or
bang in the middle as to what local
housing need is
to be able to come up with that that
figure i'm saying there's a shortfall
against the government standard method
the government's expectation of this
authority is to deliver 362 dwellings
per year
says in the paper from mr pinscher
that the local housing need does not set
a target for the number of the homes to
be built as advised by the national
planning policy framework so it's a
starting point for calculation
absolutely the local authority would you
agree has not yet
set the target number for the housing
need over the next planned period from
2025. yeah it's not it's not set its
housing requirement but the government's
expectation as you rightly point out mr
pincher rightly points out is that the
the starting position the minimum number
of homes to be delivered to meet needs
here is 360 dwellings per year
minimum it doesn't say minimum in his
life but but in the framework and the
planning practice guidance which talks
about the local housing need is the
starting point
which is the minimum
number that this authority is expected
to meet
to address its housing needs we'll have
to agree to disagree it doesn't say in
the paper he says his local authorities
take into account land supply
constraints such as green belt
in setting the need i i'll i'll agree to
disagree i'm going to move on i'll agree
to disagree
but i would invite the inspector to
read the
relevant parts of the framework and the
practice guidance as to what the
government's expectations are when it
comes to local housing need and plan
preparation
right i think so we're probably done in
terms of asking questions
okay
so yeah are you saying you have no more
questions to mr pycroft you're just
double checking or what i have no more
questions for mr pycroft okay thank
you okay
what i said was that of those interested
persons who've spoken if they have a
question
on mr pycroft's evidence that hasn't
already been raised
this is right
i want to ask something but i can't i
can't give you a reference well as long
as long as it relates to mr pinecroft's
evidence
and it does relate to the local plan
so i was looking at the local plan the
other day
i believe it was finally agreed in 2012
and
in reference to scr8
it says a minimum of 500 houses
it also says that the that scra will not
come up for consideration until 2021
unless there are exceptional
circumstances
okay so i understand that you've put
forward a cumulative number of houses
that
are the the shortfall in rochford i
totally accept that
so i just want to check on something
that i've heard
you seem to have agreed with mr foster
that the actual minimum figure
uh that that we need to bring forward
and build within each year at the moment
is 360.
correct mom it's 362. okay great and i'm
fairly certain i also heard mr foster
say
that in the last three years
that requirement has been met
well it that's not quite right because
the 362
has not been met in the last three years
but the way that government has measured
housing delivery over the last three
years
uh it's met the the government's
uh target for the housing delivery test
okay and sorry if i can just elaborate a
little um so
the reason why government isn't saying
meet 362 over the last year in
particular was because of the impact of
covid so it reduced that housing
requirement 360 figure
by
uh
four months
okay to take into effect and what that
meant was that actually if authorities
had
uh you know a build rate then it would
have met the housing delivery test
um but as we've put in the housing um
statement of common ground they haven't
actually met the 362
in the last okay so on some measure
by the skin of their teeth they've
managed to meet whatever is laid down at
the moment yeah well i don't know
whether i could categorize the skin of
the teeth but yeah they've met the
government yeah they've met the housing
delivery test correct okay so the thing
that confuses me then in view of the
fact that
by
this measure
that i managed to have
met it
um
how in your opinion
does that then constitute
exceptional circumstances for bringing
forward this
um
this development
prior to 2021.
well yeah just a few points if i may
first we don't need to demonstrate
exceptional circumstances you'll
appreciate
exceptional circumstances mean a
particular thing in in planning um
to do with green belt development and
particularly green belt release the
site's already been released from the
green belt it's already been allocated
for development post 2021 and and we are
post 2021
and and if i may the the um
relationship with the housing delivery
test is that's one measure government
expects councils to
meet the housing delivery test but it
also expects them to
keep a five-year housing loan supply and
therefore the ability to meet housing
delivery tests every every year going
forward
so
the two are related but there's two
measures for the government expectation
if you were not an expert but you were a
person that lived in rochford who had
been looking at the local plan since
2012 and you'd been categorically told
by the local planning authority that
this this this development would not be
considered until 2021
how do you think you might interpret
that as a
normal person
well
yeah sure it'd be difficult for me to to
answer that but what i can say is um
firstly local planning authority
shouldn't have told you that because
there is wording within the plan both
the core strategy and the allocations
plan that sites that are identified post
2021 could come forward before then i.e
if there's a shortfall of five-year
housing on supply and that was a
deliberate
mechanism that was put in by the
allocations plan inspector um so i think
it i don't know i'm not saying that
you've been told that or or not but you
shouldn't have been really because right
there was there was that that plan yeah
the other thing is we know um the other
two sites in that policy the post 2021
policy have come forward in advance of
of 2021 and and as i said actually
uh it's about delivery and our site
whenever the application may have been
made um
we are now post 2021 so we're in fact
we're a little bit behind um as to where
the trajectory imagined this site to
come okay
um
and
the last thing i'd like to say to you um
you've given a very detailed account
of why you think um more than 500 houses
is um
required
is it do you think it's is it laws or
um is it is it their responsibility to
to uh
to fulfill
the the housing requirements for
rochford is it as a private company is
it their responsibility to do their very
best to
uh deliver on
[Music]
a short form
well the uh an answer to the question
ultimately is the council's
responsibility to to to bring forward
sites and it does that by
um allocating sites in the plan and then
approving planning permission when they
come forward so i know that well
in an answer to what the applicant's
role in that is is to make sure that
they submit a scheme that is in
accordance with that development plan
both in terms of its principle but also
meeting things like for example um the
density policy and making best and
efficient use of land so there's there's
responsibility on
on both ways in terms of the actual
target there's no there's nothing from
you know there's not a housing delivery
test for homes for example or um
a requirement for them to meet a
five-year housing land supply that's
firmly on the council but in terms of
working together to bring forward the
site
the responsibility goes both ways okay
so
so basically it's the responsibility of
the council
to try to deliver as many homes as
possible
not
your company well the council uh sorry
uh hopefully i'm
speaking across purposes
it's the council's responsibility to a
make sure that it meets its uh how its
development plan
what it set out in its development plan
that's that's one element of it two to
meet now the local housing need which is
this 362 figure per year
and part of that will be to bring
forward sites
with developers that are capable of
of delivering it so it's not
as many dwellings as possible it's to
meet those needs and requirements and
that's the council's responsibility and
a house builder whether it's law or
someone else can assist them doing that
by
um you know securing planning permission
and and building homes in the area so in
your opinion then how much weight
should be given to the council's
definition of how many houses should be
brought forward for this site well well
um uh
full weight but
as you heard on thursday we're in
complete agreement on the principle of
662 dwellings on this site is is
appropriate that that was in council
shaw's evidence and and
hopefully you were here or if not
watching on the uh on the youtube
okay
thank you
thank you
okay thank you this is right
sorry who else was there another hand so
remind me of your name please
good afternoon
sorry this is just a point of clarity
hopefully for for me just looking at the
site plan
and i believe you mentioned this earlier
so i'm hoping you're the right person to
direct this question to
so in the site benefits you mentioned
the community center
i did yeah i can hear you yeah yeah as a
sight benefit
can i just um clarify it is this to be
designed built and paid for by blair
by bloor
so so the the land um we're going to
come onto the section 106 agreement
later so there might be a bit more
detail for you than i can give but
effectively um the land is
gifted or sold for one pound to the nhs
and then there's a
[Music]
a contribution towards that as to um
as you know as
sorry there's a contribution towards
healthcare which could be used towards
the um the new facility okay so where
we're talking about on the planet says
community center
yeah community centre there's not
necessarily a community centre that will
be built it could be built if the nhs
decides to take up the offer of buying
the land for a pound it could but the
land has given over to them
all for a pound um so then it did you
know the onus is on on the nhs to
to uh
so it's not community center as such
where we're thinking sorry yeah youth
club understood yeah for the community
it's necessary so in um
yeah it could be used for healthcare it
could be a community center if the nhs
aren't aren't using it
um as such or a combination of of the
two so potentially that space that's on
the plan as you come exiting the site
is the space that we're talking about
that could be a community center it
could be an nhs building that's right
yeah so it's that that part of the site
is only we're only looking for outline
planning permission because we don't
know what it would be or what it would
look like but the
um the reason why we can
include it in the benefits list is
because of the
section 106 agreement which ties in the
um
the uh obligation to to uh to to sell
that land
i appreciate this is probably a
completely different conversation if
we're talking about the section 106 but
if the nhs doesn't want to buy that land
what then happens to that land does it
get offered to the local council or
i would need to check in the section 106
i'm afraid so perhaps that's something
that we can check
okay because what i'm trying to
understand is i thought it was a
community center but that's what it sort
of says on the plan
but obviously i'm not an expert on those
these matters
and it mentions they're the 12 there are
10 parking spaces
if we're looking at those parking spaces
being available for parents dropping off
their children and that does turn out to
be a health care facility
all of those spaces are going to be used
up by people using the facility
so
i'm in my mind i'm thinking that the
parking spaces need to be at least
doubled or trebled to actually have a
benefit to the community yeah well so so
if i can um
try and explain so they so the community
sensor the area of land
and what they've done is they've worked
out what's
what size of building could go on there
and then what their parking requirements
would be
so they've got community
parking spaces shown on the plan and
then school parking spaces shown on the
plan
and then again sorry deference of 106
discussion but
within that there is um
an obligation to have management of
those spaces at certain times of the day
ie drop off and pick up so that they
would be actually used for um you know
school school pickle so the ten parking
spaces that have been referred to
previously
to assist parents
they're
in addition to this other piece of land
yeah correct yeah and in addition to the
parking for that commute for the
community right okay
okay that's fine i just wanted to
clarify thanks yeah thank you so
hopefully the 106 session will um
so i've just been posting out don't
worry you said which essentially says
that um the 106 nhs money could go to
the hospital
instead
to the this community that's that sure
yeah it could um i think and i think
that's right and we'll come on to um to
what that obligation is
um you know what what it says in the 106
later
all right thank you
okay thank you
i didn't see any other hands from people
who'd spoken earlier
so
um i'll see if i've got any
questions i think
as is often the case and as i've said
before as the inquiry progresses things
that i
had flagged get answered in one way or
another so just let me
i'm just looking through first of all
through mr gascoigne's evidence i think
there was there was one thing in here i
was still
wanting you to clarify hopefully you can
for me
please
yes i think let's bear with me no to
this
it's when i get to page 21 in mr
gascoigne's evidence
gives me a footnote
of
an appeal
which relates to the very top line on
that page where his talking about supply
of housing should not be viewed as a
ceiling but a baseline
and all i really wanted to know is is
that
appeal
one of the core documents because
there's
all i've got there is um
[Music]
an appeal reference number
and answer your question sir i'm afraid
i don't i don't know because i don't
recognize the pins reference number
off the top of my head but obviously we
can find find that out
for you
yes i mean clearly it's it's something
that mr gascoigne has raised and he
wants me to be aware of but i didn't see
it i don't think it appears as one of
his appendices does it
it's definitely not in the appendices
whether it's in the um in the core
documents or not is uh i did have a
quick look and didn't spot it but
perhaps if that one can be
located for me please of course yeah
apologies okay and then
okay so then turning to your
evidence but again i don't think there's
anything
oh yes there was it was one on on your
evidence
um
sorry to spare with me
it was just so i understood what you
were telling me on your page 23
i've got that in the top diagram and i i
just
wondered
what what the negative
figure of about 200 appears to or or the
how that's explained yeah sure so um so
i don't know whether you've got the
housing statement or common ground to
hand
i've certainly had it no i was going to
say not essential not essentially yeah i
got it
um and you can see sir on page seven of
that there's table five
yep and um net affordable housing
completions in watch for over the course
strategy period
so the 131
um
each year is the green line on my charts
okay and then the blue
columns
match those in column three
and you can see so that some of them
have a negative figure
or is it in fact a zero figure
and some have positive figures
and the large line that's in 2012 13 is
a minus
196. it's the difference between the one
three one and the three two seven
um
no sir it's
it's the actual well it's
confusingly it's under the title
affordable housing completions but
actually what will have happened that
year is that there have been demolitions
or uh stock loss in in some other way
yeah sorry i was i i wasn't looking at
column two when you you you oh sorry i
meant column three yeah i meant column
three so i've got it clear now yeah yeah
so um but but
um for your notes sir these figures are
all from the council's annual monitoring
reports
which i don't believe go into the
reasons why there was a you know or
which sites these were delivered on
or demolished but my
view is that they that the reason why
there was such a loss that year
and that's affected the overall figure
is because there would have been either
demolition
or or a loss you know for example right
to buy um
which is which is it's not unusual yeah
i i thought demolition was possibly the
answer yeah yeah there was no there was
no specific reference in that amr for
for example
a certain housing estate being
demolished or whatever okay
i think i think that was it then so
thank you mr pycroft i have nothing more
for you um is there any re-examination
then okay
oh bear with me
yes i've got both of those thank you
sorry start again you're asked a number
of questions about the council's
potential housing number in their
emerging plan you recall yes i recall
that yeah um can you just have a look at
first point please at the letter from uh
the right honourable christopher pincher
mp
second paragraph
bottom of the second paragraph
what is said there about ensuring that
there is an adequate supply
of housing well it's saying that they
want to achieve 300 300 000 homes
annually by the mid 2020s
one million homes over the term of the
park of the parliament and therefore
it's important
that local planning authorities plan
positively to meet their full housing
needs
second point in respect of the framework
you referred a number of times to the
minimum expectations of national policy
can you turn up please paragraph 61 of
the framework
yeah i've got that thank you bear with
me a second sorry
um
and we see it paragraph 61 to determine
the minimum number of homes needed the
minimum number of homes needed strategic
policies should be informed by a local
housing needs assessment conducted using
the standard method in national planning
guidance unless exceptional
circumstances justify an alternative
approach which also reflects current and
future demographic trends etc you see
that yeah i see that yep
in respect to the council's strategic
options consultation document
is there any consultation or indication
that this authority
is advancing or has consulted on
an alternative approach in terms of
paragraph 61. no it's not it's in in
there they're following the the standard
method
um next point please um paragraph 141 of
the framework
um and this is the test that applies
where an authority is contemplating
green belt release
and before
an authority moves to considering sites
coming into the supply from greenbelt
release what is the authority required
to do mr pycroft well it's um it tells
it to
examine fully all other reasonable
options for meeting its identified need
taking that paragraph into account and
the paragraph we've just looked at
paragraph 61 of the framework do you
agree or disagree
with councillor shaw's evidence
with councillor shaw's evidence
that it is inevitable that the appeal
site needs to come forward to meet the
critical housing needs of the authority
moving forward i agree with councillor
shaw's evidence you next point you can
put that aside
um just back to the
plan please
and in particular
the core strategy
policy h1
sorry not policy h1 policy h3 and
appendix h1
bear with me a second
uh and you were taken you were taken do
you have that yes sorry yeah i've got
that thank you document 6.1 page 48
and you were taken to appendix h1 by mr
foster in questioning you recall that i
do yeah and it was put to you that well
um in terms of po in terms of um
in terms of appendix h1 it talks about a
requirement for local highway capacity
and sorry local highway capacity and
infrastructure improvements including
contribution to traffic management of
ashingdon road now if we actually that's
in appendix h1 we actually look at what
the policy says
what the policy says
um what is appendix h1
to be read in conjunction with
uh so it's so there's reference to it in
policy h3 and
appendix h1 is to be read in conjunction
with policy clt1 right so let's turn up
policy clt1
you've got the page reference and that's
page 92. thank you
and we see in policy clt1 this
the council will require developers to
enter into legal agreements in order to
secure planning obligations to address
specific issues
relating to developments including
requisite on-site infrastructure and the
provision of on-site affordable housing
now just pausing there
does the reference to local highway
capacity and infrastructure improvements
in appendix h1
does that therefore relate to matters
that cannot be secured through section
106 obligations no it doesn't
and what is the agreed position in
respect of the appellant and the local
planning authority
as to whether the
um
section 106 obligation
addresses relevant issues in respect of
the development there's agreement
between the two parties
so taking policy
clt1 together already in conjunction
with
read in conjunction with appendix h1
in accordance with the
requirement of the policy
has the infrastructure that is required
for the residential area
been provided in accordance with the
terms of the policy
it has yeah
any dispute between you and the local
planning authority
in respect of compliance with policy h3
of the development plan no and it's in
the statement of common ground and
councillor shaw um agreed on thursday
thank you very much mr pikecroft thank
you no further questions
okay thank you
so um i just need to check with you miss
reed the statement that i referred to
when i opened today from mr harrison you
said you hadn't had the opportunity to
see that then
i didn't know whether you've had the
chance to do that
now
no sir we don't have any further um
evidence that we need to call in respect
of that okay so we'll just take that
submission as a written representation
obviously it'll be before before me when
i reach my decision okay thank you
so um we'll have an afternoon break now
that so
just to be clear that concludes uh the
evidence for
the appellant it does thank you sir
so we we've got the section 106 and
conditions session i'm flexible as to
which way round we deal with those is
there any preference from any other part
um so so now i'll just i'll just take
instructions on that and just so you're
aware i'm not going to be here for that
session because i'm going to be writing
closing submissions
um i'll just take instructions in
respect okay
so i'm in the same position i won't be
here and i'll turn to my left to find
out if there's any problem yeah
well as i say i i'm
i'm happy to deal with them in whichever
order the parties find it easiest to
deal with so
so it might help to deal with conditions
first perhaps because um there are a
number of them i think and then move on
to the 106 obligation yeah let's let's
do that then if everyone's happy with
that
so it's 20 past three if we have another
15-minute break um if is that sufficient
for everyone 15 minutes 20 minutes
so could we just sorry i i say i'm not
going to be here but i just need to make
sure that i move my boxes et cetera so
we just allow say 20 minutes let's let's
say 20 minutes then we'll come back and
deal with conditions so i'll adjourn now
we'll resume at 3 40. thank you sorry
sir may i i don't believe that rule six
parties involved in these next two
sections
it depends whether you want to be um
that there's no obligation for you to be
i mean clearly the section 106 relates
to an agreement between
the local planning authority and the
appellants
[Music]
in the sense that you're not in a
position to influence it then clearly
you you you possibly consider you play
no part whether you want to hear what's
said uh is perhaps a different matter
conditions um you
again all i'm looking at at the minute
in the conditions is suggested
conditions which have
in large part been agreed between the
appellants and the council but there are
some disagreements there
but again it's it's certainly open for
um other parties to uh give me their
views on those so i'm not trying to
persuade you one way or the other but
what i'm saying is you're not debarred
from attending
these sessions and and contributing if
you so wish to the conditions session
but equally if you feel that you've
nothing to to add or want to add to them
then uh i don't require you to be here
for them okay i don't i don't think i
can add to those either those um
two other small points see i mentioned
the ringway jacobs stuff earlier on the
two sheets i've got the copies here
um i'm going to hand you the mick fan of
stuff and it's up to you sir whether you
use it or not though
i'm happy to accept the the note that
you've done about the the jacobs because
that related to information already
before me and that's a clarification
point the other is something i don't
know about but mr vanner has his
opportunity to speak and i've taken what
he's given already so hand in the first
of those two but not the second and a
final point if i may sir tomorrow when
we do our uh closing speeches
is it okay if we split our time between
myself and mrs austin
i don't see any problem with that as i
say the i'll be emphasizing this to
everyone please bear in mind as i've
said throughout that the closing
submissions have to be a summary of your
case to date uh
as presented to the inquiry it's not an
opportunity for any fresh evidence to be
understood at that time
the only thing i would say mr foster if
you're going to disappear now um whether
you're um
whether you can tell me who's going to
attend the site visit for the
rule 6 party i will be attending this
yourself okay
you did say one person didn't you
well i i i'm content with more than that
i think miss reed said in terms of
access onto the site itself
that would be limited on the public
highway clearly you know as many people
who want to attend can but um you know
within reason would always be
a nice thing and i prefer to if that's
possible certainly
in terms of on the site itself i'm not
quite sure how um
the opponents view that
sorry so we have no problem um with both
coming onto the site it was just it was
more a general point about lots of
people and we don't can't get permission
but we're quite happy for both to come
onto the site itself okay thank you
it'll be yourself and mrs austin
yes yes okay thank you um
i don't want to take any well i'm taking
time now aren't i so let me just make a
note then so it's going to be mr foster
and mrs austin
let's just do this quickly now then for
the council who's going to be attending
please
yep
katie fowler
and who's going to be for the appellants
please
uh it's mr blair and mr pycroft
any of the interested persons wanted to
attend the site visit
i'll take that as a no thank you
so i don't want to say too much
we can go through it in in detail
when we're actually meeting on site but
just so everyone knows where we're
meeting i i've got the suggestion from
the council meet at 8 20 tomorrow by the
wall of the rochford day nursery at the
hall road west street ashington road
junction 8 20 there
okay
if everyone's happy with that i've eaten
five minutes into my 15 minutes so so
into my 20 minutes so so let's now
despite what i said a moment ago i'll
adjourn now and we'll resume at 3 45.
thank you
[Music]
i
again
um
exceptionally
okay
time
um
who is that
so this guy here get his name
well the inquiry is resumed ladies and
gentlemen um
i'm just trying to work out what i've
been
handed here i've got a
large version of the sill compliance
statement
i've not got any more conditions yet
though is that are they going to wing
their way to me now or
thank you
i think does that differ
it's the same as that then yes thank you
so basically what i've got
let's just do it this way
i've got
a schedule
that was handed in earlier on in the
inquiry saying appellants comments on
draft conditions it looks so i've been
given
an updated track changed version of that
now
so this goes through a total of 52
conditions
and then
i've got a separate
two-page document where
it tells me that a number of conditions
are agreed between the parties
a number of conditions are considered to
require a minor amendment
and then
a number of conditions that aren't
agreed and i think the second page is
then just a
run through all of those
with
whether they're agreed or not so so
basically is is presenting the same
information in a different form isn't it
the second page
yes uh just to just introduce myself i'm
robert e burn i'm a planning director
with law homes eastern uh yeah just to
clarify with there's there's not an
awful lot of difference of opinion on
these matters so there's a few
the minor amendments some of them are
related to drawing numbers which i think
are picked up on on this
and then i think some of the ones which
are not agreed
they are looking at the six tests of
conditions um
and and uh the cell compliance um yeah
certainly some of those are are
just generally quite regarded as
unnecessary so
um and that's obviously your judgment
sir so
um
i put a comment against those where uh
the reason why um they are not agreed
but uh in in general i want you to take
away the message we are generally happy
with the conditions and also i just add
that they
that from our perspective the source
data for those conditions uh comes from
the committee
essentially the first committee report
which you'll you'll
you'll remember was um
then added two by the second
and the preamble to that we we did have
a a ppa with council where which and one
of the subject of headings of that was
to look at planning conditions
and um and the run-up to the first
committee we had a a meeting uh with
katie rogers who's um sat over there and
um
where we had a cordial meeting with one
of these zoom meetings but that was on
the um 12th of november 2020 when we
kind of ran through a kind of final list
and
which is essentially very similar to
this this list you have in front of you
now okay okay well
in terms of how i was going to ask you
to deal with this basically what i
normally do is ask
particularly when we've got members of
the public here and people watching on
the live stream
we need to just go into perhaps a little
bit more detail than if it was only
participants but
what i would ask is one side or the
other to lead off and i
suggest the council but i'm happy uh the
other way if you want basically i just
want you to very briefly go through each
of the conditions tell me
an overview of what it's meant to do
why the council considers it's necessary
and if the appellant agrees then just
say agree and i'll put a take but where
there's debate um then obviously i'll
hear what one side or the other wants to
say
you'll have received um
hopefully some comments that i made
which were fairly straightforward but
there's quite a few of the conditions
where it didn't have that little phrase
approved in writing by the local
planning authority
and a few things from memory when i went
through that there were documents
referred to but in a rather vague way
and i felt they needed a bit more
precision to that so so hopefully
they've been taken on board in terms of
the reasons what i've just done prior to
the break is turn up the 24th of june
committee report because i know that the
conditions oh no i said
i know i thought the conditions there
had given reasons um it looks as though
so so there are um can there are reasons
for the conditions that are appended to
the lpa's um appeal statement
um there was the the list of conditions
and the
the reasons can be found there as well
the lpa appeal statement so right so
it's statement of case for the appeal
yeah i guess so i've got them in
different places i've just not got one
composite document is what you're saying
okay
so
we've got a lot to get through so we
don't want to spend any longer than
necessary but obviously we've got to do
justice to them so
for the council then if you'd like to
kick off and as i say just work through
them one by one and tell me why they're
considered necessary um and i'll
take the opponents to you
okay thank you um so condition one um is
a standard condition relating to the the
time for implementation
and i think that's agreed subject to a
slight change to one of the plan
references
that's correct yeah yeah and sorry
the first time i've actually looked down
at this document and i realized that one
of the track changes is to include the
reasons on here so so thank you for that
yeah and sorry what i was um what i have
got in front of me is
they have got reasons in now so
hopefully we can send you an electronic
version of this as well but they've all
got the reasons transferred from the
committee report in
um so okay so so sorry just uh i i spoke
over people there so the the the first
one standard condition but there is an
amendment because uh the plan reference
was incorrect at one stage that's
correct
okay thank you
so condition two relates to the
submission of reserve matters in respect
of phases two and three and that's
agreed and the reason's been added
so condition three
is a is it standard condition again
relating to the time for implementation
and that i think now is agreed subject
to again
a minor amendment to the ref the plan
reference which was just i'm missing a
couple of digits
yes thank you agreed
yep thank
you condition four is a condition that
requires implementation in accordance
with a list of um plans submitted um in
relation to the application um the only
amendment sought to that condition was
the deletion of the word complete
so the development shall be approved in
either complete accordance with or just
in accordance with we're satisfied that
we can remove the word complete
um condition five uh is a condition that
relates to standard external facing
materials to be used in phase one um and
they're prescribed to be as per set out
on pages of the design code that was
submitted what i've done is reference
the design code
and the reference is taken from the
the title page of that document which is
p18-2019
underscore 66 dated december 2019
i've also added in um to the last
sentence in writing by the local
planning authority i think that was one
of the points you raised it was but i'm
not saying i'm not i'm not seeing that
on the document in front of me now
apologies
i should have mentioned that um
we got this um hard copy so you had an
up-to-date version but i hadn't managed
to put all of the address all of the
comments that you'd made in that email
but i have in the document in front of
me on the laptop okay yes i'll verbally
say them but they won't feature on the
hard copy
what hopefully i'll do at the end of
this session is forward you
the the electronic version that i've got
yes well let's do it like that yeah i'm
happy with that yeah yeah if you've got
any issues obviously we can mop those up
before we move on to um the um
closing submissions tomorrow but
excuse me
so i was struggling a bit there because
i heard what you were saying but i
couldn't see it here so i wasn't quite
sure if i was on the right page there
might be a few of those then because
i've taken account of all those
yeah okay so so in a nutshell you've
given me
a reference to the design code by um
it's
a number that appears on its title page
title page yeah
yeah that addresses some of my issue
about sort of vagueness of conditions
later on so i'm happy with that yes
okay okay so
content with that yes yep okay thank you
okay
so condition six
so condition six relates to phases two
and three only because phase one would
benefit from full planning permission
um so what it seeks to do is ensure that
we
achieve compliance with policy h5 which
relates to a dwelling mix across the
site
in terms of
the number of bedrooms for different
drilling so one two three bed
so
i
it's the condition is there to ensure
compliance with policy h5 however you'll
note i've got some
lengthy comments in relation because i'm
just grappling with whether it's
necessary myself um having reflected on
it because
um phases two and three will require
reserve matters submission um in
relation to scale
so
potentially if the local authority were
not satisfied in relation to the
dwelling mix proposed observed matter
stage
that might be a matter on which they
might take issue with approving a
reserve matters consent um
so i guess it's for you sir to decide
whether or not that's
necessary in light of
whether that
it only relates to phases two and three
doesn't it yeah yeah so it relates to
phases two and three but the phases two
and three plans do set out the uh the
mix of housing on on the plans on those
specific drawings with which we're being
asked to comply with
um under condition for
so
and if the council it might be
unsatisfactory to the appellant if the
council were to then ask for
uh the mix of dwellings to be
all one bedroom flats on phases two and
three then that would go against what we
feel is
the application
i think we're in agreement that
providing the mix as proposed in this
outline application is achieved in
relation to phases two and three that
we're satisfied that that mix is
acceptable in relation to policy h5
it's just that because scale is not yet
for determination there is i guess
potential for reserve mass application
to come in that might be different um
but then i guess we might not have
accordance with the
the plans that are listed
as approved plans well you say the the
the plans so the plan i've seen plans
for phases two and three yeah in in the
context of the section 106 agreement yes
i'm not sure if i've seen them do the
the plan the plans list here
uh in um in condition four
uh is um the plans list is includes
phases two and three
layout and that one it's sort of halfway
down the page of page three yeah ending
in o3s
that that plan is the plan which
sets out the the complete layout for
phases two and three
uh and includes a schedule of
accommodation which that layout matches
up with
yeah so if so if the development has to
proceed uh in
you've got rid of the word complete i
mean but in in agreement or whatever
in accordance with i mean completely in
that context completes kind of a
superfluous word i suspect
so
what's the consensus there is there a
consensus
on on this
condition six
i think i am i minded to say that if the
if we if the the plan is listed as a
plan as an approved plan
um
if the appeal in the event the appeal is
allowed um it will only grant
outline with layout so the positioning
of buildings within the site that is
approved for phases two and three but
that plan does also have a schedule of
accommodation on it
it's whether
um the outline specifically requires a
call you know
accordance with that schedule given that
scale which goes to building size
essentially is not yet
determined
yeah
any comments on that yeah i come back to
my earlier point if
we we don't we
the the mission is based upon a layout
which achieves a broad mix of dwellings
and doesn't propose
a significant number of say four bedroom
properties or a significant number of
one-bedroom properties and if this
condition gives the opportunity for the
council to then refuse a proposal which
um
which varies from this mix that might be
problematic i'm not quite sure what what
really what the purpose of this is if
they agree with the plan
that it's acceptable in terms of
mix
then there's an opportunity for for
the applicant
the appellant to then vary that mix if
they want to apply for a uh
variation of that condition for
section 73
yeah so i mean what i've got at the
minute is is a
suggested condition from the council
then i've got an amended condition
uh amended
a suggested amendment should i say um
with quite a detailed note that i
haven't yet had the chance to
to look through in detail so
i'm still
unclear as to whether or not there's
agreement between you as to whether or
not a condition like this is necessary
and if so in which form
it should take
well i i think it doesn't seem to me
that this has been this is suggested as
necessary because the plans and and
indeed the committee report are all
based upon the mix of the housing so
there's a there's a discussion within
the commission report both which reports
about the mix
and that it's acceptable um so
and if there was a
um
[Music]
i
don't i don't see there's an opportunity
to vary that if the layout is is
accepted
yeah
anything final from the council on that
one
i think we're kind of on the same
i mean the amended condition seems to be
similar to the the existing condition
but i think the council are satisfied
that they were content with the mix as
shown on the um plan submitted at the
outline stage the layout plans it feels
like it's a sort of almost
for the avoidance of doubt kind of point
isn't it yes so
so you seem to be saying that you're
uncertain as to whether the condition is
actually strictly necessary yes
with the plans that are going to be in
and certainly if that dwelling mix
that's annotated or shown in a table on
the layout plum phases two and three
were the dwelling mix we are satisfied
with satisfied with that yeah
okay
well i've heard what you both see i mean
another alternative would should be that
the
dwelling mix should be as per the
um uh set as set out
on on that plan
uh unless otherwise agreed in writing i
mean that said
yeah
they're not um
that allows the council
but it just allows the council to
approve a variation to it if
to remain to remain in control of it
should it be proposed well i wouldn't
want to be in a position enough as if
the council were to
if the council would then if i was to go
for a maybe a discussion with the
council about those two phases and they
said actually we've changed our view on
mix now we want it to be
much larger units and much smaller units
and that wouldn't have been something we
would be planning for it would be a bit
of a surprise and that condition allows
for that surprise at the moment
yeah okay i think
i don't i don't want us to to spend any
longer no
on on a single condition i've i've heard
what you've both said i think i'll just
have to reflect
on that if uh if i'm minded to to allow
this appeal
let's move on to seven then okay seven
um
uh we are agree
we agree that that condition can be
deleted because that is dealt with in
the 106.
okay
yep
eight and nine
are a joy to go sorry do you shall i
just say what eight and nine are yeah
yeah um so condition eight relates to um
archaeological investigation works and i
think there's there's already agreement
on the wording of that condition
and condition nine
relates to um
again to the archaeological works and a
post um excavation assessment
being submitted i think there is
agreement they're both agreed are they
yeah
condition 10 relates to the
non-residential building at the site and
the community building and
the environmental sustainability
credentials relating to that
and the briem rating are very good being
required
there was suggestion of a slight
rewording to this
which starts concurrently with the
submission of reserve matters
i'm satisfied with that rewording i had
just had a comment in the margin about
the timings of that
in terms of time
dealing with the discharge of condition
application under reserve matters
application and one decision might come
before the other but
in summary we're happy with the
amended wording and the reference to
policy should be emv10
right
so happy with the amended wording there
yeah
okay
um condition 11 relates to um badger
sets and work
in and around those badger sets there's
just um the addition of two words has
been part way through the condition
which was in your reference your email
sir so that's been um that's not in your
version but it is in in the version on
my screen
um
other than that there's no change to
that and i think that's agreed
condition 12 relates to invasive species
on the site japanese knotweed and
that condition
stemmed from a consultation response we
received from an ecologist at essex
county council
but i think
we we accept so that if you're satisfied
that that's dealt with by other
legislation then it's not necessary
so that's the that's the view of the
appellant it can be deleted on there
yeah it will be dealt with but it can be
deleted it's not necessary to have it as
a condition
the condition condition 13 relates to
works to existing trees and hedgerows
and the protection of nesting birds
so the comet that that again stemmed
from a consultation response from our
ecologist at essex county council
i think what the appellant says it's not
necessary
we do impose conditions similar to this
and
one has been imposed by an inspector
recently in relation to an appeal um
what we would say is that this requires
um
restriction on works just to those parts
of the site where the
hedgerows and trees are to outside the
bird nesting season and less
unless agreed so essentially it requires
an ecologist to give the okay to those
works and i think we would say that this
um
is is still necessary but i think the
view differs i i'm i'm happy to
to take that uh uh
my in some some authorities see them it
was unnecessary
and um some wouldn't use them but um
from our perspective it's it's
unnecessary because we have
responsibilities in any respect
um under um environmental protection act
so with
something we we do is our due diligence
in any event
so sorry just so i'm understanding that
you consider it's unnecessary
did you did you say you were content if
it did remain yeah so i'm content if it
remains yes yeah
okay thank you
okay condition 14
um relates to tree protection plan um to
protect trees that are going to remain
um there's just a typo that's corrected
so with becomes within on the second
line that's again from your comments sir
but otherwise i think that's agreed
yeah okay yes condition 15 relates to
the provision of um bird and bat boxes
as sort of enhancement mitigation
measures
um arising from the development the
i think the condition is agreed but
there are some
um there's just an expansion of pos to
public open space
and i've also put um the title um of the
ecology report in in full so it now
reads as per report titled ecological
impact assessment final revision e by
southern ecological solutions and then
the date of issue is the 10th the 12th
2019
um and then also adding in agreed in
writing by the lpa so that deals with
your comments nothing that's agreed
yeah agreed yes
um condition 16 relates to reptile
mitigation strategy and the need for one
to be submitted and agreed and then
those works as agreed implemented
the comment has come back that that's
unnecessary because the reptile
mitigation strategy has been implemented
i think my only comment in the margin is
um this of this condition stemmed from
our ecologist having read through that
ecological appraisal
there is reference in that ecological
appraisal to the mitigation strategy
needing to be um submitted and then um
reference to it being conditioned so we
just haven't seen that mitigation
strategy if i could just clarify um
there's a
slight confusion on my part because
in between the committees we did carry
out ecological mitigation um but that
has yet to be completed so there is some
further works which will happen late in
the late spring so i'm happy for that
condition to be retained now
okay so if that condition is retained um
when you say
right that's okay so there's a partial
we've done part of the it's a weather
depends on the warm weather so our our
um some of our reptile um work works
were carried out in the um spring and
summer of um last year and they will be
now completed in the late spring of this
year okay i think as much as anything
when i first read that i just read it as
reptile mitigation strategy and thought
is this another one where we need a
better defined uh but when i read it
again now it's asking for that to be
submitted to an agreed in writing isn't
it so that satisfies that point so yeah
okay so so
as as as it stands um and you're content
with that yes yeah okay thank
you yeah
okay
okay so yes condition 17 relates to um
a scheme for surface water drainage to
be submitted and this condition is is
lengthy but it's the requirement of the
lead local flood authority so it's kind
of word for word what they'd wanted and
i think there is no comment in relation
to that so it's agreed all okay thank
you
condition 18 relates to
again
what surface water but during the
construction period the comment um has
come back that this should be within the
construction environment management plan
at condition 52.
i think our only comment is in terms of
discharging the conditions this um deals
with a flood risk issue as opposed to
other aspects of the construction
environment management plan
and so we as a rule sort of generally
keep this condition
in isolation on its own um and send
those details through to the llfa to
look at
so just procedurally it's easier if this
is separate so it makes it easier if
this is separate and not
rolled into the
cemp yeah um but what we have got again
is um
i think again from you sir your comments
the the last sentence the scheme shall
subsequently be implemented as approved
prior to commencement of construction
or or according to an alternative
timetable so there's an implementation
yeah time frame added to the end of that
condition
yeah yeah we i mean just just coming
back on that we
obviously the mppf says
planning conditions should be kept to a
minimum so um what we tend to do is um
we found that
we have obviously deal with lots of
different local planning authorities and
we tend to
um prepare a
construction environmental management
plan which covers all of these
eventualities so that the the um
the construction drainage will be within
that document in any event so
um we provide we're basically preparing
one document which will be covering off
more than
one or two conditions doesn't it doesn't
really matter to us it's just that's
just how we would deal with it so if
it's in the if it's in condition 52 it's
fine as long as it's there somewhere the
council is content yep and and frankly
if there were no conditions we'd still
be preparing the document so it's not a
problem for us
okay
right thank you
and condition 19 relates to
maintenance arrangements for the surface
water drainage scheme and frequencies of
maintenance to be agreed etcetera i
think there's agreement that the only
comment that's been addressed was one of
yours and it just relates to in-writing
so that reference has been added in okay
um condition 20 related to foul the foul
water pumping station and boundary
treatment and landscaping of that
i don't think there's any
difference i think that's in agreement
condition 21
relates to
the details of this site flood
alleviation scheme which is separate to
the
surface water drainage scheme
and that stemmed again from the lead
local flood authority so that's their
wording of that i don't think um there
was any comment from the appellant
yep okay
condition 22 relates to strategic open
green space within phase one
um and it includes the east-west green
corridor the centrally positioned
northern green space the eastern
partland
and it relates to details being in
accordance with a set of approved plans
relating to landscaping
um
there were some comments in relation to
the plan references which i agree um the
slight tweaks to those just in terms of
um
um
and then just another typo has been
addressed so i agree that um and the
design code has been referenced in full
in the same manner as throughout now
yep okay so that's
so sorry that was the first bit of
condition 22. but then going down
because there's a number of boxes so
there's been a couple of more references
below to imprecision in relation to some
of the bullet-pointed aspects that we
consider should be um included in the
details that are to be submitted
yeah um
i think sir they've been worded as
precisely as we think we could get them
but uh if um
alternative if you consider alternative
wordings necessary then
are you are you still of the view that
there's some imprecision in these aren't
yes this hasn't changed and what we we
commented on previously but um
what are naturalistic head walls to suds
features indeed are they possible to be
naturalistic that's
the term um
and then also details of existing trees
to be retained including reconsideration
to retain a greater proportion of
existing trees within the central tree
belt along the east-west ditch i mean
it's
it's just all
playing around with that with the with
the
plan that you plans that we are
complying with
so
let me be clear how are you uh are you
suggesting a way in which they
could be made more precise
it comes back to necessities isn't it
what
what is it
we have a condition which requires
exist says where existing trees are be
to be retained and then we've got we've
got another one which says
um include
can reconsideration i mean just it's
just not a
this is vague
um
it's a very unusual sort of set of kind
of requirements in a long little very a
very long list
yes i i i'd have to go through that a
bit more slowly to actually take on
on board the points that you're
both putting to me here
i can see obviously the
first set of amendments is
straightforward because it's just really
getting clarification of the correct
correct plans there
but then in terms of what the
rest of the condition
covers
so it's just
so it's just saying in the start of the
condition is saying
do them in do these in in conjunction
with the approved plans and then it goes
on with a list of
various other elements which
are kind of slight variations i'm not
quite sure what the purpose of this is
but but are those as as you've turned
the slight variations are are they
matters shown clearly enough on the
plans such that if the if the
development proceeded in accordance with
the plans then all of these bits are
well no that's the thing that's my point
is they're not they're kind of extra
things which we don't really know
what what they are and what the extent
of them are
[Music]
so some of the sorry i'm just slowly
catching up here on this so some of them
are
acceptable as it were i'm just quickly
looking on the second page where it says
signage boards to explain the provision
so you you you you've not put a comment
alongside no it's just those where i see
the word imprecise yes
so
let's just concentrate on that is
is there any way that
between you you you can see a way of
tightening up that
because at the minute i i i can't
without looking at the plans myself and
looking again through this condition in
a bit more detail i don't know if there
was anything i could suggest so i'll be
just at this moment relying on
your comments as to whether or not
those bits can be tightened
if it helps um maybe it it might help if
i explain where some of these things
came from okay um so in relation it says
so the second
i think well the first bullet point that
has an imprecise reference next to it
talks about um details replacement
hedgerows shrub planting including
natural including to naturally buffer
the badger sets on the site and provide
new connecting hedgerow planting etc i
think that that comes from
the ecological report in terms of
enhancement
so and what this is intending to do is
essentially when we come to discharge
the details that are submitted we make
sure we're capturing all of these things
that so you would check that alongside
the ecological report
we these things are taken from the
ecological report essentially and then
when we come to discharge the condition
we know what we're looking for rather
than having to refer back to
reports that were submitted that that
cover much much wider considerations um
again similarly with the signage boards
um yeah sorry i was just thinking then
could the ecological report be
referenced in the condition but that
sounds always perhaps
it could be perhaps referencing the
reason for the condition so there is
some
some acknowledgement of where these
additional things are uh that's it
yeah
it's not it's not a
as i said an opening for this it's not
we don't have a particular disdain for
any of these conditions but it's um it's
a point nonetheless
okay so
there's at least
three areas four areas aren't there
where there is some
lack of clarity as to perhaps what's
required
i think there's three points and then
the last one relates i think
perhaps to the implementation timetable
for delivery um
but
my comments i don't if there is a
comment in the margin or whether that's
an updated comment i'd put in but
actually i think in terms of
implementation perhaps this is dealt
with in the 106. it is um
and i think in the 106 but correct me if
i'm interpreting this wrong
it says that the open space should be
provided prior to 25 occupation in phase
one and all of the open space on the
phasing plan falls within phase one
yes so this is
again the
the starting point for these conditions
is precedes the wording in the section
106 so that this is now covered in the
section 106 so maybe put a sort of a
margin in a marker and when we go to the
section 106 you'll see where this comes
up so are you saying there that this
particular bullet point
is
covered by covered by the 106. so
perhaps that one doesn't need to be in
here so just let me so less yeah
okay so i can i can consider that but in
in terms
just so i'm clear
have we
found a way of resolving this um
imprecision as as the appellants see it
i think if you as you say as katie
helpfully suggested if you reference the
ecology report in the reasoning that
would help with
those discharging the condition doesn't
it yeah okay so so
reference the ecology report
okay
so
happy to move on to 23.
yeah sorry i just lost my space um
23. so this relates to hard and soft
landscaping um performing part of the
entrance avenue planting so this is in
phase one
and
the the comments come back that it's
replication the requirement to deliver
the development in accordance with the
approved plans but i think this goes
slightly further because it requires
um
this to be
implemented
in a timetable it does say to be agreed
so there is some flexibility over that
well that's to be agreed between
with the local planning authority but it
also requires
specific tree planting in relation to
that provided in the pages 46 and 47 of
the design code
right
and the design code has been referenced
in full
your views then
i haven't got a problem with the answer
given i think that's fine no no problem
with
yeah
so
okay condition 24 relates to um tree
planting um adjacent to the highway
between car parking
spaces and areas of grass verge it
relates to a plan reference there was no
comment i don't think on this one
and what has been changed is just
a specific reference to the design code
okay
um 25 again there was no comment it
relates to tree planting
and the design code has been referenced
and
approved in writing has also been added
in the words in writing okay
condition 26 relates to hard and soft
landscaping
forming on plot like amenity space
within phase one um so that's separate
to the open space that's kind of
publicly accessible um the comments come
back
i guess imprecise i guess in general i
think rather than specifically relating
to certain bits what i have done is
sought to reference the design code
um so throughout
that has gone in
um
that's helpful yeah yeah
i didn't have a i didn't have a
condition 27 on my list so
if you're coming on to that
where are we
uh
actually i'm now on 28 i don't know what
the previous number was so so hang on
do we go from 26 to 28 or is it just a
27
missed out here
i kind of spotted the absence of a 27
after i'd gone through everything and
probably about two days later and saw
there was no 27 on my list
but
was it like that on the original one it
would be helpful to go back to the
committee report because um just to make
sure that we aren't missing something
yes but um i don't know
i haven't got a copy of
that condition
oh yeah there was no yeah there was no
27 in the list that i was working from
[Applause]
it might be
just it's not numbered uh 27 was in the
committee report
yeah so there was a condition 27 maybe i
could just add it into the table
um that relates to hard and soft
landscaping of a specific amenity space
within phase one
yes so just let me be clear first of all
because 26 is hard and soft landscaping
isn't it so
so 26 is the one we've just been talking
about yeah there
and that you you going to
reference the design code
and the opponent's happy that that
resolves some of the
imprecision
is that correct yeah that's correct 26
is in relation to kind of on plot
people's private amenity space yeah and
27 relates to hard and soft landscaping
of a specific amenity uh sort of
publicly accessible open green space um
at a particular point within phase one
oh that's just street five have a new
one yeah okay that's that's fine so does
that not appear in this list at all has
it just been
it just doesn't appear in the list i
don't think unfortunately sorry
i think it might have just been when
it's been transcribed it's similar to
the previous conditions so it might have
been an error that's crept in
on that basis i think what i'm
hesitating about is when i look at 26 26
starts off on page 18
and then it follows with a whole load of
bullet points
and just looking back in the committee
report
that is indeed what that one did
but then it goes on
and there's a lot more bullet points on
page 20. so
i'm just trying to see whether whether
the second set of bullet points relate
to condition 27
it looks like they do they do
i think what's missing is just um
the first
opening lines of that
of condition 27 are missing aren't they
the first bit so the first or paragraph
of condition 27 should all should be
inserted
but actually that's the only bit that's
missing actually we do have condition 27
it's just not in its own box
and and not all of it there not all of
it's there yeah so
this is all i know of labor in this but
let's just be clear so 26 ends in the in
the committee report
with the words uh
whichever is earlier and retained in the
approved form
so
is that on here for 26
um
so any three
yeah it does it is that because it's
just
the word form appears just above the
reason
on on page 6.30 of the
of the
committee report
yeah no
i'm in the committee report and i can i
can see the condition
[Music]
i just
can't see it all
so basically we've got the bullet points
and the last one is planting
pan
so again planting plans
but then in the committee report it
follow it goes on with the hard and soft
landscaping as agreed
whereas that's not what i've got in
front of me here i've got any tree shrub
or hedge plant
i think i think that the bottom line is
rather than wasting any more time on
this one now it's clear that there are
some words missing it may be the that
introductory sentence from
um condition 27 but there's something
not there that should be there in this
schedule
so
let me just check because obviously once
we've finished this session
the next time that we're back at the
inquiry after we've done the uh section
106 is going to be tomorrow afternoon
for the closing submissions
when will an updated version of this be
able to be emailed to the inspectors
case officer so i can have a look at
that will that be
later today are we talking about
tomorrow for this
we could probably do it later today
if you can then what i'm really getting
around to is i can have a look at it
before we have the session on closing
submissions and if there are any points
that either side wants to raise then
about conditions and if i do at least we
we can do that and be all talking about
the same
updated document
does that sound reasonable that's fine
yeah and so my only real comment here in
terms of these conditions there is now
another one because 27 wasn't was a gap
is that it's
the requirement to replace planting is
kind of repeated three times throughout
and it just seems a bit unnecessary yeah
i'm afraid that's often the nature of
conditions isn't it but
indeed i've made the point in the margin
that i don't disagree with you that it's
like but i don't know if it can be
captured in any other way unless that is
a separate condition in itself that
relates to all the others above but um
yeah i i think it may be one that uh if
again i have to preface it if i'm minded
to allow this and impose these
conditions it may be that we just have
to have that repetitive element that's
fine
okay so
tell me again about 27 even though we've
not got the beginning of it in the um
the schedule in front of us now yep so
condition 27 relates to details of the
hard and soft landscaping very specific
part of the kind of publicly accessible
green space
part of the site within phase one
yeah
okay
right let's go on to 28 then
28 relates to the play space it's going
to be that will be provided within the
eastern park land um
so
there's there's a couple of comments in
relation to this um
one in respect to the in perpetuity
reference they're being
provided in perpetuity and the other
saying that it's within the 106. it
we're satisfied that it is in the 106.
um
the the i've got some comments down the
side my comment would be that i think
the condition had related to an approved
plan reference in respect of the play
equipment details because that part is
within phase one
um and if the appeal were allowed full
planning consent has already been would
be granted for those details so
potentially the 106 could be worded such
that it's in accordance with those
details
and the plan reference
but i think otherwise we're satisfied
there is an implementation clause in the
106 that we understand means that the
play space has to be provided prior to
25 occupation within phase one
where where does that in the section
106. no no
because i haven't had a chance to go
through all of your comments yet where
does that leave the council oh what's
the council's position there sorry yeah
the council's position then is we're
satisfied that condition 28 could be
deleted because it's dealt with in the
106.
and that's also the appellant's view of
the thing yes yes yes
okay
29 then 29 deals with the mountain bike
trail that would be provided with an
eastern parkland as well again the um
condition reference is a specific plan
reference um but we are content that
that is dealt with in the 106 um
as well so again council's content that
that could be deleted yes yeah
okay
so condition 30 relates to
a sort of smaller um what we've
referenced as an informal play space
within the open space adjacent to the
northern boundary so that's relating to
phase three or closer to phase three
the only comment that's come back in
relation to that condition is
the reference to in perpetuity
in terms of it being retained in the
form that's been approved and i i don't
quite know what the alternative to in
perpetuity is i think in relation to the
play space
the foot the kind of big play space and
the mountain bike trail in the 106
there's a requirement for it to be
maintained
um
i don't think i don't know what the word
is it's more where equipment is provided
and then
it becomes responsibility of a
management company and then over a
period of time
that equipment might change and and and
be a different type of equipment and
whether it's by agreement so you don't
you don't necessarily have an in
perpetuity clause in relation to
something which
might be upgraded or replaced in due
course it's not not the case that we're
looking to
remove player equipment once it's been
installed and normally it is just saved
maintained uh and and retained in the
approved form but without necessarily
in perpetuity reference
okay so if you're happy with maintained
and approved in the
surfacing
should be maintained in the approved for
sorry the equipment be maintained in the
approved form
yeah that's fine i think that's okay
yeah so will that will that apply to the
others where there's this imperative
phrase so or
are they different um
i think we're satisfied that if we're
not referring to in perpetuity as long
as it's maintained in the approved form
that's essentially
the same means the same thing without
using the without using those words
that's fine
okay so
agreed like that yeah
okay um 31 deals the um requirement for
boundary treatment to the allotments to
be submitted and agreed and then
implemented
um
the the comments that's come back is
that the allotment provision is within
the 106 which it is but i don't think
there's a specific reference in the 106
to the boundary treatment being agreed
so possibly i think this condition could
be retained but we're satisfied that the
implementation time frame can be amended
um to the appellant suggestion
instead of reference to the 50th
occupation reference to prior to the
allotments being laid out
okay so the council's view is the
condition itself should be retained but
the implementation
should relate to the prior to the
allotments being laid out is that
if i understood you correctly there yes
from the appellant are you content with
that yeah okay
okay
32 then please 32 relates to um
a condition about renewable energy um to
seek compliance with policy emv8 of the
core strategy
and i think the
the comments that have come back is that
a slightly alternative wording
is proposed to specifically refer to the
fabric first approach being adopted
and we we have no
objection to that
so
i think we're satisfied with the with
the rewording i think your comments are
has been that the sustainability
statement that um has been referenced in
the alternative wording should be
clear you know referenced in full yeah
so we can i can put that reference in so
so the council has no objection to the
alternative wording
and you will put in a more precise or a
referenced
uh
a reference to the sustainability
statement yeah and for the appellants
obviously that was your suggested
amendment
yeah
okay
um condition 333 relates to the
provision of wheelchair accessible
dwellings um with reference to
optional building regulation
requirements um part m43 and m42 and the
number of dwellings that should meet
those standards to comply with policy h
six um
in respect of condition 33 this relates
just to phase one and these this is in
the 106. there's a requirement in the
106 that already sets out that um
these number of dwellings meeting this
standard will be provided the only thing
that the 106 doesn't do is require the
developer to evidence that those
dwellings have been provided to accord
with that standard and
we would like that um we think that's
necessary
so that we don't have a problem with
that yeah
so either we can retain the condition
in that element or the 106 would have to
be slightly amended to
i'm assuming the section 106 is in a
position where you're hoping to not be
amending it
such that it's easier to deal with the
condition
uh yeah if we keep the condition yeah
happy with that yeah
um
[Music]
condition 34 is similar so it relates to
wheelchair accessibility dwellings but
only but in relation to phases two and
three
um
in terms of the requirement for the
number and that is in the 106.
um because the
what's proposed is that um the
wheelchair adaptable properties are all
delivered through affordable housing so
it's in the affordable housing section
of the 106
but again the evidence bit isn't in
there so i think we still need it
so if i turn over i'm going to see that
same bit about evidence right yes so so
it's it's that element of the condition
that leads the council to the view that
it wants to retain it is that yes
yeah that's fine happy with that yep
condition 35 relates to um an optional
building regulation requirement relating
to water efficiency being required um
and the council have suggested the
imposition of this condition with regard
to policy emv 9 of the course strategy
and the comment is that that is out of
date
and we respect that it is out of date
and so much as um
our view is that the min a ministerial
statement in october 2015 has to be
taken into account in relation to it but
our view had been that because we had a
policy that required
a sort of higher end water efficiency
standard that we could require
compliance with this optional building
regulation requirement
what's the appellants
i'm not sure i think my reading of this
is if you if
you have a policy you can impose it if
you don't have a policy you don't impose
it but um
we have we haven't got a particular
problem with complying with it
um
it's fairly
i think it's fairly um on a technical
basis it's achievable but
the council don't have a policy of
acquiring it and my understanding was
that part g was optional based upon the
council
adopting a policy in a local plan which
says that you should
um meet that
part of the building regulations
okay
well
i've heard what you each say on that i
think i'll just have to
form a view
um condition 36 relates to contamination
and i think perhaps the version you've
got might just say
actually sorry i do have a version yes
it does your version i think
i don't know actually sorry i don't if
your version just still says
contamination full detail of wording of
condition to be confirmed
but what i have proposed is the standard
condition wording in relation to
contamination
um
i don't know if we can accept that the
appellant suggestion that
there's no contamination on the site as
evidence investigation report and that
we only need that bit of the standard
condition that relates to unexpected
contamination being reported
and i say that because i think the
contamination report does reference the
need for further ground testing and gas
monitoring um a certain
point in the ground investigation report
which i have referenced in this updated
version but that's not the version
you've got in front of you okay i can
see something in the comments
highlighted in yellow oh sorry that
might be there then yeah
you have maybe got that comment then so
if the comments there
just
explain to me what the council's saying
that
its preferred version of this condition
should be then
so what i've done at the moment is put
in our standard text um so that's the
one that starts with prior too that's
the one that starts with prior to each
phase of development it doesn't
necessarily have to be phased but um
that's the one that yeah
okay
it might be that that could be could be
tweaked amended um because we have you
know already had the essentially the
preliminary risk assessment and proposed
but my concern with just limiting this
condition to unexpected contamination is
that it would not necessarily address
that point in the
appellant's submitted report that
suggested further testing was required
right
stay with me
so
how does the appellants
sorry how did the appellants respond
to that then please it well
it's fairly typical isn't it we you
one gets asked to submit uh details of
whether or not the site is contaminated
you submit the details do all the work
and then the condition asks you to kind
of do all that work again so
it's
it's a use there really if it's um if
you feel it's it's required then um
we'll obviously have to um revisit that
and um
uh try to convince the council yet again
that the site is not a contaminated site
and and then submit all the evidence to
prove that and obviously that the
wording that condition is a standard
wording and that covers off that
eventuality does it does rather make a
mockery of of having to submit all the
details in advance but
um so be it as i say with me just come
into some of these points afresh now it
does seem that the highlighted bit there
if i'm reading that correctly it does
refer to something which was in
whatever this original investigation
report was but indicating that further
testing work was
required
so from that point of view it does sound
as though the council's
suggested condition
would take that on board i think it
would i accept that it might be
overly onerous but um maybe we could
look to sort of um reword it to pro to
another problem
administratively it's just painful
having to deal with something when
my my technical experts are not here
um will tell me that this this is all
dealt with and there's not a it's a
field it's not a it's not an industrial
site it's just a field without
um significant contaminants so um but
i'm happy to the
with the imposition of outstanding
condition if that gets past this point
right
so that takes us to 37 doesn't it
yep 37. um this relates to the vehicle
main vehicle access to the site off
washington road
and i think there was no comments um
from the appellate um
your reference
to
the words in principle yeah given that
it's an approved plan and it is an
approved plan reference so i think this
stemmed from the essex county council
highway
suggested conditions and their reference
to in principle
whether the technical drawings might be
slightly different and show more but i
think we're satisfied that we can take
away the reference to in principle and
keep it to that um
approved plan reference
the um
i think the reason in principle is
written is because
these that's the way
the engineering advice works is that you
when when um accesses get their formal
approval
via the county council there are
sometimes minor technical changes to
those drawings just just as as you go
through the process and also i would say
on this condition i i didn't pick this
up early in my earlier comments but
there is a sort of second sentence there
which looks like it's a
a stamp being extracted from a standard
condition relating to a kind of
domestic access it just seems a bit of
an odd wording i accept you know put put
it in accordance with the plan but it
needs to be in principle but
um to allow for very minor kind of
changes but this middle sentence just
seemed and i i did speak to the to um
actually mr blair when he was here and
it's and we kind of looked at that a bit
puzzled about that second sentence
because it implies it's a drop crossing
yeah i i
i went through this very quickly what i
did i was also confused as to why we
were referring to a dropped curb
vehicular crossing it sounded more like
a private access um yes i think it's uh
it's been
it's the source for this um to be
helpful is i think from
essex county council and they they tend
to code their reasons
um
and their conditions and it might just
be a sort of a bit of wording that's
kind of crept in
in in error but you know the point of
the condition is quite laudable which is
to make sure the the axis is provided um
um
uh in in in a timely fashion
i think the key point as we've been
going through this is there are clearly
what i'm looking at now isn't the final
version that both sides are either
agreed on or
you know where you disagree
so
in that same context when you're looking
at this later today or over tonight
overnight whatever if you consider that
that middle sentence really doesn't uh
apply in this case then obviously i'd
ask you to remove it in the version that
i hope you'll be
submitting
tomorrow or later today
okay let's let's look at 38 then please
38 then deals with um the provision of
the emergency vehicle access um
associated pedestrian cycle way onto
ashington road
again this this we have the same um in
principle comment so if you're satisfied
that we can keep the in principle
reference in
that has come from essex county council
we have no objection to the in-principle
reference it is listed as an approved
plan though
i don't think there's any other comment
in relation to that
i think that was agreed
yep yes yes
um
and then 39 deals with the vehicular
access onto percy cottis road this is
the secondary vehicle access to the site
so the comment received was that these
works are within the 106 and that
there's no requirement to open this
access by the 50th occupation
um
i think the same in principle comment
was there
and that is an approved plan again so
you know however you feel about leaving
the in principle in um
what
we i have done and i can't i don't know
what changes you see but i think we're
content to
um
omit the what we can the prior to 50th
occupation is is not something that
you know
we desperately need to
retain we can have a discussion about
when that is provided we think the
secondary access
should be provided um
and we're not convinced that this is
dealt with entirely in the 106 given
that
i think part e of the off-site highway
works definition in the section 106
um requires improvements within the
highway on percycottis road
but
i'm not certain that that covers the
formation of the actual access
into the site okay
it came up in highways evidence and that
is the the
in general the modeling of traffic is
based upon a kind of broadly an 80 20
split so
it
this this axis is not required
um
before
the
before 80 occupation of the site
so so so
to force us to
provide an access to access early
is
there's no evidence behind that at all
so what we think is that the there is
still a need for this condition because
i don't think the formation of the
actual vehicle access is covered in the
106 but what i have suggested is that we
remove the words and associated
improvements so the condition only deals
with the actual formation of the access
point because the improvements otherwise
on percycottis road is a clause in the
106. so it's it's the the bit covered by
the wording associated improvements that
you're saying is in the 106. but the
formation of the access itself you don't
think it is and then
a prior to 50th occupation um is in
there but is open to this
discussion about when but certainly we
think that the secondary access
needs to be needs to be provided so
there needs to be a requirement via
condition that it is so you're saying
that there needs to be a triggers
some form of trigger and then just to
refer to the plans uh four phases two
and three the
this access is actually within
the plans four phases two and three it's
not within phase one
so so your requirement for it to be the
50th dwelling on that basis is is
incorrect because
it would have to be after the 232nd
home yeah yes so
if i'm understanding you correctly there
the according to the plans you don't
need this until phase two or three well
in i think the traffic assessment
assumes this access comes into play at
80 percent occupation
of the site so if you were to create in
indeed just add a zero to to be
part of the
500th occupation that that's what the
traffic evidence says
right
so what have i got here in terms of this
comment
party
if that's the council's current position
you're suggesting the conditions
retained consider alternative timing and
omit the reference to the
associated improvements so the
associated improvements i i understand
is because that's in the um
section 106 but
what are you saying would be an
acceptable trigger
for the council
instead of prior to 50th occupation
um well certainly we agree that it's in
relation to phase two if we could just
say be prior to the occupation of any
dwelling in phases
yeah that's
prior to ok
of any
dwelling in phase two or three
at least two or three
yeah okay well i i've noted that but
obviously you'll be amending that in the
version that you've got
there which i'll be seeing later
okay
so 40 then please um 40 deals with um
formation of hard surfaces in
developable areas within each phase i
think that's stemmed from from the
highway authority and there's no
comments in relation to the wording of
that condition i think it's agreed okay
and 41
deals with um no well it's just a
requirement that there's no unbound
surface treatment within six metres of a
highway yes
i think that's agreed we're not we're
not a fan of those
um condition 42 and deals with the
provision or requirement for the
provision of electric vehicle charging
points
um there was a comment in relation to
this
um
that it should relate to
just as well a slight rewording i think
of the initial sentence so prior to
first occupation at the site details of
provision of visitor electric vehicle
charging points
which is fine i mean the condition
already says to serve visitor parking
but
we can amend that um as suggested
so so um amend amending the first part
in accordance with the appellant's
comments yes would work there what's
this bit about the um in perpetuity
that's yeah i mean
we would be satisfied if it said
maintained as agreed
well maybe operational yeah
again again these things get upgraded in
future and
[Music]
that's that's the point of that it's not
i've got a particular issue with the
word but
just allows them to be upgraded and
improved in future
okay
okay and you've already heard of this as
a wider strategy for electric vehicle
charging points across the site which is
separate from this so this is
this is the publicly accessible bit yeah
yeah
okay
i'm condition 43 um
seeks to
ensure that
parking provision across the site is
maintained for the
purpose of parking you know
no other purpose essentially
and i don't think there's any comment in
relation to that i've just added in the
reason
we've got the perpetuity word there
haven't we yeah and i think that i
haven't got a particular issue with that
because that's um
in effect you're you're saying that if
someone wants to change their parking to
another use i.e depleting the site of
parking spaces then in fact they had to
apply for planning admission for that so
it's service stretching on permitted
development rights
so that
as long as that's clear you
then
we're quite happy with that
sorry you're happy with that yes and
it's funny
thank you
okay 44 and deals with the residential
travel pack um and we're satisfied that
that's now in the 106. so that can be
deleted so you can delete here
yeah this com this is a little bit
historic because it says six one day
travel vouchers and now we're proposing
three months yes i thought i've seen i i
know that came up in the inquiry
at an earlier session but i i knew i'd
read through the travel plan or whatever
and thought
there was a different figure so yes so
so get getting rid of that condition is
acceptable yes
okay so
45
45 deals with the provision of a
segregated foot and cycle path within
the eastern parkland to link oxford road
to the south and the drive sorry the
other way around oxford road in the
north and the drive to the south i don't
think there was any comment in relation
to that wording of that condition
okay
46 um
so this deals with pedestrian
connections through to ashendon road
from the site yeah and there was
it relates to approved drawings and
there's no comments in relation to that
okay
47 deals with
a lighting scheme to open space
throughout the site and there was no
comments in relation to that
sorry 47 should i say dealt with
lighting to the open space
i think and 48 deals with lighting to
the pedestrian footwear connection
through so the footpath connection would
be formed to ashendon road there was no
comments in relation to that condition
either right yeah 49 deals with dust
management and the comment was that this
should be in the construction
environment management plan which we
accept so that needs to just go into the
wording of condition 52.
that can be deleted as long as that
wording's contained in 52
condition 50
relates the provision of cycle and
refuse stores for the flatted blocks um
and the requirement that that provision
is maintained there is a reference to in
perpetuity again so
as long as it's maintained in the agreed
form you know we're satisfied with that
we could change that reference but there
was no comment in relation to that
okay
um 51 deals with um
the institute
sorry
um
yeah 51
um requires that there aren't windows
provided to just certain plots within
phase one and that's in the interest of
amenity but there's no comment in
relation to that one
and then 52 is the construction
environmental management plan which has
been referred to um what i have done is
just
um add in a sort so it should be
complied with throughout the
construction process
in the as as per the agreed form so i've
added that reference in just think is
something you picked up on
and i've also added in in the second box
the site-wide
plan shall be shall include but be not
limited to i think that was a reference
you picked up on
um we accept the amendment suggested in
terms of um
the wording of b which relates to whole
roots
um
just scrolling and then dust managed
dust management came into that didn't it
because that was in a previous is that
gone in there now that will go in it
hasn't gone in but it yeah it that's
that's i can see d says dust management
and wheel washing
is that a different one too
no maybe it is in there i think maybe
that
it was a condition dedicated to dust
magic 49 was dust management so that's
the 49 can go as long as it's included
in the and i'm saying look so it might
already be there under d
yep
that's fine
and there's a the final amendment
related to point p
um any archaeological protection
mitigation measures to be implemented
during the construction process a slight
rewording of that which is fine
okay
good so that's it so there's thank you
for
going through those there's still
obviously some work to be done to
produce a a final
final form i think we're nearly there
and the list has got shorter so that's
helpful yes yes some of those so so
what i would obviously like is those
where there's agreement that it can go i
don't need to see them there
i suppose it's not nice for me to see
what it is that's been deleted but as
long as it's clear that uh both parties
uh are content that that can go
uh and obviously incorporate
within the final list the reasons are
here so that's good
the amendments are there so i'll leave
that in in your hands but if i can see
that um
ideally later today or or early tomorrow
so that uh i've got that well in advance
of the resumption of the inquiry thank
you
okay so let's call a day on that i think
i'm just kind of a short 10-minute break
if
everyone's content with that and then
we'll come back and
hear about the section 106.
so it's
just gone just gone five past let's
adjourn until quarter past five please
sorry we've got the latest version of
the 106.
i was given one earlier
okay
um
okay
we
um
that's what i'm thinking
yeah foreign
you
what have i got here this is the one
with track changes
so this one includes that manuscript
change there
okay and i can explain those
okay
yes okay well the inquiry is resumed so
let's move on
hopefully with the final business of
today to deal with the
propose well with the submitted
section 106 agreement basically what
i've got in front of me is
the agreement and the still compliance
table
all i really need is for
one side or the other or a combination
to just take me through the agreement so
i i can understand
what's proposed what the obligations are
etc
so i think
as we were kind of in charge of the
drafting we we will take you through
that on my right is nick harding and who
has been leading the drafting on this so
i'll let him take you through hopefully
quite quickly as we seem to be
gathering gloom outside yes
yes well clearly um
it's an agreement
it's
his very name tells me that so
there's there's no
disagreement but as i say i just want to
make sure that i've been taken through
the uh
through the agreement so i understand
what it's intended to
achieve okay
thank you sir um so i'm nick harding
solicitor for bloor homes
and senior associate law firm gowning
wlg um
if i'll tell you i'll take you through
the agreement the um
party agreement are the current
landowners abel limited aw square
limited and dlu square limited and bloor
homes limited who have a contract um
relating to the purchase of the land
rocha district council in their
capacity's local planning authority and
essex county council in their capacity
as local education and highest authority
and in respect of waste services and
libraries and as you say is an agreement
between
all parties um and all parties have now
executed the um the engravements um just
just an administrative point first um i
understand you're given um a warning
last night i hope
that due to time constraints we executed
in counterparts and while i appreciate
that
the planning spectra usually do not
consider this appropriate method of
um execution
um there is some leeway in exceptional
circumstances and
as we
were still yet to
reach agreement with the county council
last tuesday
and with six different parties to sign
uh we all agreed that it wouldn't be
signed in time to close inquiry and
especially at that time the inquiry
could have closed on on friday so i hope
that's good for you yeah i understand
that and i think in those circumstances
i understand why that course of action
was taken and i i don't see that that's
not acceptable if that makes sense it
does thank you sir the double negative
there yeah
um in terms of the um clauses in the
front end of the agreement i think the
main clauses to note are at clause 2.13
which is
a clause that allows you to make clear
in your decision letter
whether
an obligation containing the agreement
does not meet the
um
tests of the community infrastructure
regulations
um and it
allows you to essentially strike out
such an obligation and leave the
remainder of the
deed intact
the phase
clause 6.4 allows the phase plan
appended to the deed to be amended at
any time by agreement
between the
parties
um clause 6.5 there's an obligation on
the owner to give notice to both the
district council and the county council
of the various triggers relating to the
obligations
clause 6.11 provides that the parties
agreement are to be released from
liability under the deed once they're
parted with their interest
in the land or or part of it
and clause 20 at the end of the
agreement contains uh
clause clause 20 sorry at the end of the
front end contains a clause that that
provides that the agreement can be
executed in counterparts
right yes
and i think unless the district council
have any
comments i think those are probably the
most pertinent points in the front end
of the agreement
i don't have any comments
okay thank you okay so schedule
one
of the section 106 agreement relates to
affordable housing
and it provides that 35
of the dwellings provided um
on the land are provided as affordable
housing in a 10-year split of 80
affordable rented housing and 20
shared ownership housing yep um as we
discussed in the condition session the
location of the affordable housing units
is fixed as per the phase layout plans
which also
agreed plans in the conditions yep
the unit mix of the
affordable housing is also fixed as per
the
tables contained at part four or
schedule one
in terms of um
size
of the houses to the number of bedrooms
yeah okay um
the only outstanding details are
the tenure of each unit and location of
the accessible and adaptable affordable
housing units and the wheelchair
affordable housing units and the size of
the units and those details are to be
approved by the district council
upon submission of an affordable housing
scheme
by the owner prior to commencement or
development
okay
and also as we discussed previously 20
of the affordable housing units are
provided as wheelchair accessible
housing uh sorry wheelchair affordable
housing units and 72 affordable housing
units are to be provided as accessible
and adaptable affordable housing units
the owner has under an obligation not to
occupy more than 60
of the open market dwellings within each
phase until 50 of the affordable housing
units within that phase have been
constructed okay and also not to occupy
more than 80 of the open market units
within each phase until 100
of the affordable housing units within
that phase have been constructed
the schedule contains
an industry standard
mortgagee exclusion clause
which provides for the
an outcome whereby the mortgagee of a
registered provider of social housing
were to take possession of the um
affordable housing units
and there's also an obligation on
the registered provider of social
housing who
takes on the affordable housing units to
enter into nominations agreement with
the district council prior to
the occupation of um the affordable
housing units
again unless the district council have
any further points that's the affordable
housing schedule
any comments there no
okay
so schedule two relates to
education
and contributions
are to be paid towards
early years in childcare education
primary school education and secondary
school education
the contributions are calculated based
on formulas that are set out in the
most recent policy
of county council um
and as we paid
in the following installments uh 25 is
to be paid prior to the commencement of
development
25
of those
contributions that we paid prior to the
first occupation of any dwellings
a further 25 is to be paid prior to
occupation of 10 of the dwellings and
the final 25 percent is to be paid prior
to occupation of 50 of the dwellings
okay schedule three
um
relates to open space
um
suds and flood alleviation scheme
the open space specification and
management scheme
for each phase is to be approved by the
council prior to the commencement of
that phase
the open space is to be laid out prior
to the occupation of
25
of the dwellings within a phase
and is to be maintained by the owner for
further 12 months following completion
of the open space um
upon which you'll be transferred to a
management company
the management company is to be formed
prior to occupation of
80
of the dwellings
within a phase
um
and
such information will include details of
how the funds for maintenance of the
open space we recruit from residents of
the dwellings
okay
the
sustainable urban drainage system is
provided in accordance with the
appropriate planning condition
um we haven't referred to a specific
condition
and because we note it that may that may
change
um and transferred to
a management company or a statutory
water undertaker
the flood alleviation scheme is also to
be approved by the district council
priority management or development in
accordance with
planning conditions which contain more
detail on the scheme
and it's to be provided prior to the
earlier of occupation of the 150th
dwelling or two years from the
commencement of the development yep okay
again okay
schedule four
relates to allotment land and provides
that 0.26 hectares
of the land within the site is to be
laid out as allotments prior to
occupation of more than 50 of the
dwellings within the site and
transferred to a management company
schedule five
um
of the agreement relates to highways um
so
the following set of contributions are
to be paid prior to the first occupation
of any dwelling within the site and
those are the ashington road crossing
contribution or 50 000 pounds
the bus services contribution of 700 000
pounds
cycling infrastructure contribution of
250 000 pounds and the pedestrian
crossing contribution of 50 000 pounds
okay
the owner is to submit a scheme
um for improvements to the in roundabout
um to
the county council prior to first
occupation of any dwellings
um and it is then the owners to elect
whether to pay the annual in roundabout
contribution or a hundred thousand
pounds to the county council prior to
occupation of
of the first wedding in the second phase
of the development or to complete the
anne berlin roundabout works prior to
the occupation of the 500th dwelling in
the development
in the definitions uh in the in schedule
5 it contains a list of the off-site
hierar works that have been
agreed between the owner and
the county council
and the owner is to enter into a
highways agreement with the county
council regarding those works prior to
first occupation
um
of
any dwelling
and to carry out the offsite homeworks
in accordance with that with such a
highs agreement yep
a
contribution towards provision and
maintenance of of trees
um
is to be
paid by the owner
um prior to
commencement or development
and the the sum of such contributions
worked out by formula depending on the
number of trees and and whether they are
um in soft landscaping or
in grills pits and
watering systems in hard landscaping
there's a provision of a further offsite
higher works contribution if the county
council
believe it necessary
within a period of five years from the
date of the planning commission
and that further offsite hireworks are
required to
uh at the ashland road and dallas road
they they are able to call upon the
owner to pay a contribution of 100 000
pounds
to go towards um
improvements along that corridor
right yeah this has included um
following concerns raised by the
planning authority
regarding the residential travel plan um
the owner is to set up a sustainable
transport fund in the sum of 101 286
pounds
and the purpose of such fund is to fund
the
travel vouchers which is the three-month
bus passes
and to to each resident of the
of the development
the owners to pay a um
res uh sorry the residential travel plan
is to be approved
by the count by the county council prior
to
the first occupation of any dwelling
um and following approval of the plan a
monitoring fee of 2 55 pounds is payable
to the county council by the owner until
one year after the occupation of the
final dwelling in the development
okay
schedule 6
of the um
section 106 agreement relates to
healthcare
the owner's covenant not to carry out
any works
on the healthcare land and shown
um on the plan appended to the section
106 agreement um
and to use reasonable endeavors to
transfer that land to a health care
provider
being
anybody organization providing services
commissioned by nhs england always
agreed otherwise between the owners and
the council
and for a period of two years from the
clinton development
as
as drafted the section 106 agreement
provides that if following two years um
the healthcare land has not been
transferred or a long leasehold interest
granted
then the owner is released from the
obligations in the schedule and the land
is retained by the owner but we would
like to propose a further amendment um
to this to to state that
in such an event the land
is to be offered uh to be transferred to
the district council for the sum of one
pound
okay
that
does that currently exist in the version
that i have here it does not so that was
that was an amendment discussed um
between myself and the digital council
solicitors um in our break session about
an hour or so ago okay so it's a it's a
recent amendment which we haven't
yet so how would how would you take that
proposed amendment forward
um we'll uh seek um
the approval of of the parties um today
um and insert insert it in manuscript um
in the uh engracements initial
council contend with that yes yeah we're
happy with that
okay thank you thank you so much
and finally in the healthcare schedule
the owners coming to pay the healthcare
contribution of 262 thousand and 300
pounds
and to the
accounts district council prior to the
first occupation
of any dwelling and the district council
are then under an obligation to pay that
contribution to the nhs
okay
schedule 7 of the agreement relates to
the school landscaping scheme
the owner is to pay a contribution of 50
000 pounds
to the district council
towards the provision of landscaping
improvements along the ashen road
frontage of and within holt farm junior
school
and the contributions we paid prior to
the occupation of any dwelling
yep
schedule eight
place to waste services
um undiscriminate away services
contribution of 75
630 pounds
is to be paid to the county council
prior to the first occupation of any
dwelling
okay
schedule 9 relates to libraries
um
the library contribution is broken down
as 244 pounds 92 per dwelling in respect
of library extensions and 77 pounds 80
per dwelling in respect of library
improvements
and the final summons we paid to the
county council prior to the commencement
of development
yep
schedule 10
relates to youth facilities
and a contribution of 75 000 pounds is
to be paid to the district council
prior to the occupation of the 50th
dwelling in the development
yeah okay schedule 11
relates to um
it's titled the rams contribution but it
relates to european protected sites so
interior 2000 sites uh special
protection the benfleet and south end
marshall special protection area
and the fallness estuary special
protection area
along with others listed in the 626
agreement
and a contribution of 127 pounds and 30
pence per dwelling is to be paid to the
district council prior to the
commencement of development
yep okay
schedule 12
of the
agreement relates to the planting and
acquisition
of a
trees
um
the
cap the cavat contribution so capital
asset value for amenity trees
contribution of 67 560 pounds issue paid
to the district council prior to the
commencement of development
and the planting stock contribution of
75 000 pounds is to be paid to the
district council prior to the
commencement of development
and the final schedule 13 of the
agreement relates to the school drop off
and pick up parking spaces which are
shown uh
labeled s
on the phase one layout plan appended to
the agreement
these
um these spaces have to be provided
to a management plan for the drop off
and pick up um
relating to the schools opposite the
site um i'm just gonna pause you there
because i've just turned to the pha the
well i think's the phase one layout plan
mine's got a line through it on here is
that sorry yes so the
purpose of this is that the the original
plans provided in the agreement were too
small to make out uh spaces and so
we've and uh right stapled and initialed
um larger plans which
hopefully you can make out below the
community use land
and the space is labeled s
yes i hadn't realized that the one i was
actually moving out of the way to look
at this plan was a larger version of the
first one so yes okay thank you for that
thank you sir so sorry just go back to
we said marked s on the yes so if you if
you open the larger plan on the phase
one layout plan below the community use
um
land
which is that white square you can
you can see um
spaces marked c which are which are more
spaces for the community
healthcare land but also space is marked
s um
at the end of the top row and all along
the bottom row which are to be reserved
for school parking pick up and drop off
yeah
so just a quick count there i see 10
spaces right yeah 10 spaces thank you
okay so management plan
um
in respect to those spaces is to be
provided to the district council prior
to the commencement of the development
and those spaces
are to be um provided prior to the
occupation of the 50th dwelling in the
development
and transferred to a management company
prior to the occupation of the 100th
swelling in the development and
thereafter
maintained a managed pursuant to the
management plan
yep okay
and that's
that is the extent of the section
experiment sir
so in terms of the plans just let me be
clear what i've got
appended here so there's
first one
appendix right
appendix one's the site plan appendix
two
phasing plan
yeah
okay
three is a health care land plan for
play area plan
then
five we've got the phase one
layout
phase
two and three
layout yeah so that's the
that's the extent of the um
uh
the plans in the appendices and it'll
just turn over to the back there see
appendix six says residential travel
plan
template certainly in and in one of the
versions that i've got of the
the 106
i've got
a quite extensive
it
um
the county council sustainable modes of
transport travel strategy was that part
of the this yes sir this is so this is
the um
this is the county council's uh travel
plan template or sustainable modes of
travel strategy
upon which the residential travel plan
submitted by the owner is to be based on
yep okay so so it says residential
travel plan template there that in
effect is the essex county council
document yeah understood thank you
right thank you so other than the fact
that there needs to be uh at least
just the single uh
additional or a amendment yeah relating
to the
transfer to the district council if
there's no take-up within two years but
that's that's the only thing
different in in what will be the final
version to what i've got in front of me
now
yeah
good okay well thank you for that run
through i've followed what you said then
i understand it all and there's clearly
agreement between the parties
on that so
i don't need anything further on that
obviously you'll be
making those uh that amendment and
letting me have a a completed version
tomorrow
thank you
but in terms of um what we need to do
now i think
unless there's anything from anything
from i think all the other people
have gone so what what i did want to say
was just about um
i want to say one thing about the site
visit but i realize that there's not
many people necessarily here certainly
some people here will be attending
tomorrow i was just going to double
check
um
ground conditions on the site itself and
what um what would be appropriate
footwear on the site
i'm expecting to wear some walking boots
so
i was just about to suggest that so
hopefully you have some walking boots
packed but that sounds like the size of
it and i don't know what the weather
forecast is but we need to state the
obvious i understand it's clear so
well
appropriate clothing and appropriate
footwear i think yes yeah
there was one other point i wanted to
raise that we've had a few questions
from third parties and i know no one's
here now about whether they will have an
opportunity to make any comments in
closing yeah understand the position
will be no
um well but if there could be some
clarity as to who
i'm going to
let me say my bit now and if it and then
if it uh if there's still anything
hanging over
then we can come back to that um
in a moment i'm going to adjourn the
inquiry until two o'clock tomorrow
that's the time that we'll be back
in this room obviously we'll be doing
the site visit in the morning but the
formal inquiry will be uh resumed at two
o'clock tomorrow
when i will hear closing submissions and
i'll hear those from the main parties
excuse me
in the order that i'll hear the rule 6
party first and i'll hear from the
council and finally i'll hear from the
appellant
propellants
now i wouldn't expect any interested
persons to give a closing statement
because
they can't introduce any additional
evidence at this stage
and i have the statements that they all
made in
um presenting their
address their addresses to the
council on the uh to the inquiry on the
opening day
exceptionally i can allow interested
persons to
make a closing statement um
but but that would have to be something
that was different to to what they
said in
in
in their opening submissions as it were
and as i've just said i can't have any
fresh evidence so so that rather
convoluted way of saying things there
anyone who's engaged in uh questioning
of the the appellant's witnesses so i'm
thinking there of of mrs wright
mr
gardner
mrs
taylor eve
there may be others but i i think that
might be the sum total
if as a result of that questioning their
position had in any way changed i would
be prepared to allow them to summarize
the way their case stands at the end of
the inquiry but for those people who've
already simply given me their opening
statement then nothing can have changed
in terms of their position
so i i hope that is clear i won't be
expecting
any closing statements from those people
who've simply given me an opening
statement and have made no further
contribution through questioning
throughout the inquiry
but i would be prepared to consider if
any of those who have questioned
witnesses
feel that anything has changed in terms
of their position
i would allow those to make a statement
does that address the points that people
have been asking you about
yes
good thank you
okay so in in the event that you get a
request
tomorrow because they're not here um and
and you feel you you need to
um accept that request because i asked
you
maintain the convention of of the rule
six
then the council then the appellant with
the appellant having the final
reply as such and then maybe take
any interested parties once rule six has
spoken
i i would take them first okay so i i
indicated earlier when uh the advocates
were
just having a chat with me all together
i did say to
mr foster
that he should come along expecting to
speak first at two o'clock but if i was
informed that any interested parties did
want to say anything i would swap them
in before him but again it would only be
on the basis of what i've just said
something needs to have changed in their
position
as a result of questioning that they've
a questioning session that they've had
with one witness or another okay
so hopefully that's clear
i'll see some of you tomorrow at 8 20
for the site visit
but other than that i'll adjourn the
inquiry oh no attendance list i need to
ask for that just before i close it's
there so i don't know if anyone's
not yet signed it so mr pycroft might
have been just raising his hand there
okay so when
that's finding its way around to me but
i'll adjourn then now and we'll resume
the inquiry tomorrow at two o'clock
so thank you
uh